ORDER THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
A WELCOME EVERYBODY WE HAVE ONE
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MELENDEZ.
THAT IS -- AB.
FIVE FIVE THREE PLEASE.
PROCEED TO THE PODIUM AND WE'RE
GOING TO START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE BECAUSE WE DON'T OF A
QUORUM ASSUMES WE DO WE WILL.
STOP THE PROCEEDINGS TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM BUT GOOD
AFTERNOON.
AND PLEASE -- OR AT YOUR
pCONVENIENCE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY WITNESSES ARE MAKING THEIR
WAY UP HERE TO THE PODIUM
[inaudible]
THANK.
HERE THEY COME.
OKAY M. AND I AM HERE TO DATE TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
FIVE THREE WHICH ALLOWS VOTERS
TO DECIDE WHETHER THEY WANT TO
CONTINUE SPENDING.
UP ON FINDING ON CALIFORNIA'S
HIGH SPEED RAIL OR WHETHER TO
PRIORITIZE THEIR SPINES TOWARDS
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING -- AS YOU
KNOW THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT
HAS CHANGED DRAMATICALLY WORD IS
NOW AND HOW.
YOU MAY SIT DOWN LADIES I'M
SORRY.
SHE HAS A BABY IN HER HANDS TO
SO -- THE THE THE PROJECT IS NOW
YOU KNOW NO LONGER WHAT IT WAS
SOLD TO TO THE VOTERS IT'S NOW
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY -- IT'S
IT'S A CENTRAL VALLEY PORTION OF
THE PROJECT WHICH IS VASTLY
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THE VOTERS
AGREED TO AND WE DID NOT.
AGREE TO A TRAIN FROM MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD I DO KNOW THAT SEC.
GIVEN THAT I THINK WE AS
CALIFORNIANS IN AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS NEED TO RE PRIORITIZE
WHERE THIS MONEY IS GOING I'M I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY SOME PEOPLE
WHO ARE DIRECTLY AFFECTED.
BY THIS PROJECT THAT I AND I
WANT THEM TO SHARE WITH YOU
THEIR EXPERIENCE -- BUT I FIRST
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT A COUPLE
OTHERS -- WHO AREN'T HERE WITH
THIS TODAY SHOW HALF WHICH WAS
PLANNING ON SELLING HER HOME --
IN MADERA ONCE SHE RETIRED AND
IT WAS INITIALLY PRAISE FOR FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
THEN THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY TOLD HER THAT THE
TRAIN WAS GOING TO BE BUILT ON
HER PROPERTY.
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW YEARS SO OF
COURSE SHE TRIED TO SELL IT AND
THE REALTORS FOUND IT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE TO SELL THAT HOME
ONCE PEOPLE DISCOVERED THAT THEY
WOULD EVENTUALLY HAVE TO MOVE
BECAUSE OF THE TRAIN.
AND THEN THE AUTHORITY -- CAME
IN AND SAID WHAT WE WILL BUY
YOUR HOME BUT THEY ONLY OFFER TO
BUY THE HOME FOR ABOUT A THIRD
OF ITS VALUE.
SO IT'S A LOSE LOSE ON BOTH ENDS
FOR PEOPLE LIKE THIS.
MITCH HUTCHERSON WAS THE OWNER
OF RIVERSIDE NURSERY AND DECIDED
TO CLOSE HIS BUSINESS DOWN AFTER
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF OPERATION
BECAUSE THEY COULD NOT AFFORD
THE RELOCATION COSTS.
IF THAT'S YOUR LIVELIHOOD OF
THAT'S IT'S PAYING THE BILLS IN
YOUR FAMILY YOU'RE TOLD YOU HAVE
TO MOVE BECAUSE THE TRAIN IS
GOING TO GO TO YOUR PROPERTY AND
YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO MOVE YOUR
BUSINESS.
YOUR LIVELIHOOD IS NOW GONE TO
THAT A TRAIN THAT DOESN'T EXIST
YET CAN GO THROUGH YOUR PROPERTY.
AND THEY WERE CLOSE THEY WERE
FORCED TO CLOSE THEIR BUSINESS
DOWN.
AND THEN THERE IS ALSO A KEY
LIMóN CAN SHARE YOU OWN FRESNO
AS LONG TIME STANDING RESTAURANT
IN JEWELERS DINER IN FRESNO SOME
OF YOU MAY BE AWARE OF THAT.
THEY SOLD THE BUSINESS TO THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY FOR
ABOUT HALF OF WHAT IT WOULD HAVE
TAKEN THEM TO RELOCATE AND HAD
TO CLOSER BUSINESS AFTER SIXTY
YEARS.
SO THESE ARE JUST A FEW -- AS
STORIES THERE ARE MANY -- BUT I
WANTED SHARE THEM WITH YOU TODAY
I DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES WITH ME
THOUGH -- HE WILL TELL YOU THEIR
OWN STORY -- RATIO DEBT MORE
FROM THE CITY OF REFUGE IN OAK
PARK SACRAMENTO AND ISABELLA
GARCIA WHO CURRENTLY LIVES IN
ONE OF THE CITY OF REFUGE.
REFUGES TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAMS THIS IS THIS IS A
DIRECT AFFECT ON THEIR LIVES AND
I WOULD JUST ASK THAT YOU GIVE
THEM YOUR THOUGHTFUL ATTENTION
AND LISTEN TO HOW.
THIS HAS IMPACTED THEIR DAILY
LIFE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING US
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS MICHELLE
DEBT MORE AND I AM AT THE
FOUNDER AT CITY OF REFUGE IN
SACRAMENTO ALONG WITH MY HUSBAND
LEARNED IT MORE.
AND WE'VE BEEN IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD FOR NINETEEN YEARS
AND OUR COMMITMENT TO HOUSING
WAS ACTUALLY NOT A PART OF OUR
BEGINNING AT RAND IT STARTED
WITH AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND
ABOUT NINE YEARS AGO -- BUT WE
SAW A TREND OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
REALLY BEGAN TO SPREAD ACROSS --
OUR STATE OUR NATION AND OVER
THE COURSE OF ONE YEAR WE HAD
SEVENTEEN YOUNG WOMEN WHO WERE
EIGHTEEN YEARS AND OLDER THAT
HAD.
SHOWN UP AT OUR DOOR NEEDING
REFUGE AND EATING HOUSING AND
EATING A SECOND CHANCE AND SO WE
STARTED WITH A LITTLE TWO
BEDROOM ONE BATH HOUSE AND WE
BEGAN.
I TAKING THESE YOUNG WOMEN IN.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
FOUND -- AS WE BELIEVE THAT
PEOPLE PEOPLE ARE AN ASSET
PEOPLE ARE NOT OUR PROBLEM.
AND FUTURE GENERATIONS ARE AN
ASSET TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND WHEN WE LOOK AT THE NEED FOR
HOUSING AND OUR COMMITMENT FOR
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA AND SAFE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IT REALLY TAKES A PERSPECTIVE
THAT PEOPLE ARE THE MOST
IMPORTANT ASSET THAT LIVES ARE
THE MOST IMPORTANT ASSET AND
THAT WE AS A STATE ARE GOING TO
BE COMMITTED TO FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
I'M ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
FOUND AS WE BEGIN TO TAKE THESE
YOUNG WOMEN AND WE TO DATE HAVE
TAKEN AND THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN WOMEN INTO OUR
HOUSING PROGRAM.
WAS AT THAT NEXT STEP FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WAS REALLY
NOT AN OPTION -- WE CAN PASS
BILLS ON HUMAN TRAFFICKING BUT
IN LAST WE HAVE AN OPTION FOR
HEALTHY AND SAFE COMMUNITIES --
WE CAN'T STOP SUCH ATROCITIES IN
OUR IN OUR STATE.
I'M WE'D THEN OPENED UP ART
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM YOU
KNOW PARK WHICH WAS A SEVEN
BEDROOM FOUR BATH HOUSE WHICH
THIS LITTLE ASSET RIGHT HERE HI
SERAPHINE I LIVED IN OUR HOUSING
PROGRAM.
AND AT IT WAS PURELY GIVING
YOUNG WOMEN THE CHANCE TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES IN THE
CONTEXT OF A COMMUNITY.
THAT WAS RAPIDLY CHANGING.
WHEN WE LOOK AT COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WE SEE CITIES
LIKE OAKLAND AND SACRAMENTO IN
LOS ANGELES WHERE WE'RE SEEING
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
REDEVELOPED?
GENTRIFIED SOME PEOPLE CHOOSE TO
USE THAT WORD.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT IF WE ARE
INTENTIONAL ABOUT REBUILDING
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES WHERE PEOPLE
CAN AFFORD TO LIVE AND TO
PARTICIPATE IN TO BE A PART OF
IT WE WILL SEE.
SYSTEMIC ISSUES BEGAN TO CHANGE
WE WILL SEE EDUCATION BEGAN TO
CHANGE WE WILL SEE.
I GENERATIONS OF HOMELESSNESS
BEGAN TO CHANGE AND SELL THAT IS
OUR REQUEST -- THAT YOU WOULD
CONSIDER -- PUTTING FINDING
TOWARDS BUILDING HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES WHERE FRIENDS LIKE
MY FRIEND ISABELLA CAN LIVE AND
SHE CAN SEE HER CHILDREN --
CONTINUE IN A TRAJECTORY OR
CYCLES OF ABUSE.
AND HORROR DO NOT CONTINUE.
BUT THEY BECOME OUR FUTURE
LEADERS OF OUR STATE.
I'M GONNA PUT A PAUSE ON THE
TESTIMONY WE'RE GOING.
TO LOOK FOR THE SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
FRAZIER HERE [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
SHARE YOUR CUNNINGHAM.
DALY HERE DEEP HERE FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
IN A IS THERE IN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
WE HAVE A FORMAL MOVE ON SORRY
FOR THE INTERRUPTION PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME THE REPRESENTING.
OKAY MY NAME IS ISABELLA GARCIA.
I'M RESIDENT AT ONE OF THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING UNITS THAT
CITY OF REFUGE OWNS -- I'M
THIRTY SIX YEARS OLD WHEN I WAS
FIFTEEN I WAS -- TRAPPED IN AN
ABUSIVE SITUATION.
IT LASTED TWENTY YEARS -- THIS
HAPPEN IN SACRAMENTO I IT WAS
BASICALLY A SLAVE -- I WAS
ABUSED IN EVERY WAY PHYSICALLY
[inaudible]
FINANCIALLY -- AND THEN I ENDED
UP.
PREGNANT AND I WAS BEING FORCED
INTO AN ABORTION BECAUSE SHE WAS
A GIRL.
BY THE GRACE OF GOD I ESCAPED.
WITH MY SEVEN YEAR OLD SON AND
MY UNBORN BABY AND ONE BAG.
AND I HAD NO IDEA.
WHAT I WAS GOING TO DO OR HOW?
I ENDED UP BUT WE'VE.
AND ENDED UP MEETING.
HERSELF.
THE CITY OF REFUGE.
AND SHE OPENED UP THE HOME TO ME.
AND I'VE BEEN THERE SINCE
SEPTEMBER.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE I'D BE IF IT
WASN'T FOR CITY OF REFUGE
[inaudible]
I HAVE BEEN GOING THROUGH SO
MANY LEGAL.
ISSUES FIGHTING FOR MY KIDS --
AND THE REASON THAT I STAYED FOR
SO LONG WAS FEAR I DIDN'T KNOW.
HOW I WOULD?
AND DO IT ON MY OWN.
AND I BELIEVE THAT NOBODY WOULD
HELP.
SO.
I'M SO THANKFUL THAT MICHELLE
WAS THERE AT THE CITY OF REFUGE
IS THERE THAT THERE HOUSING
PROGRAMS THERE THAT I HAVE A
HOME AND I CAN GO TO AND BUT I'M
OKAY.
THE TIME [inaudible]
SURVIVING.
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD BE FREE.
I WAS IN THAT SITUATION FOR MORE
THAN HALF MY LIFE FROM TWENTY
YEARS.
AND I THOUGHT THAT WAS MY LIFE
AND I BASICALLY GIVEN UP BUT NOW
I HAVE A PLACE WHERE I CAN GO
AND BE A MOM.
AND HAVE MY CHILDREN
[inaudible]
AND IT'S A PLACE WHERE I HAVE
PEACE [inaudible]
AND FREEDOM [inaudible]
SO.
I KNOW THERE ARE MANY MORE WOMEN
LIKE THAT IN SACRAMENTO IN
CALIFORNIA.
YOU MAY NOT KNOW THIS IS
ACTUALLY GOING ON BUT IT IS AND
I'M GRATEFUL. FOR THE PLACE I
HAVE SO THANK YOU.
FOR LETTING ME SHARE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR SHARING.
A FULL EXPERIENCE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME IN THE
REPRESENTING PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS ROSALIE HAGSTROM
AND I'M REPRESENTING TEACHERS.
YES ALL THE TEACHERS OUT THERE
WHO SEE THAT WHO WANT WHOSE JOB
IS TO TEACH ACADEMICS TO KIDS.
BUT WHOSE KIDS ARE WORRIED ABOUT
WHERE THEY'RE GONNA SPEND THE
NIGHT.
SO -- JUSTIN COURAGE YOU AM I
ALSO LIVE IN OAK PARK AND HOUSED
A LOT OF WOMEN AND CHILDREN IN
OUR OWN FAMILY HOME.
AND WE NEED TO PUT SOME MONEY
TOWARD MORE AB HOUSING. FOR FOR
THESE FAMILIES.
SO -- THE VOTERS NEED. TO TO
HAVE THIS BUT BEFORE THEM THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY.
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THEY LIKE TO
TESTIFIED OPPOSITION OR HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHORS BILL
THE STATE YOUR NAME YOU
REPRESENT PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN KEITH DONE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF IRON WORKERS AND
OPPOSITION AYE AYE FIRST WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT MY HEART.
GOES OUT. TO THE WITNESSES AND
THE AND AND AND AM IMPRESSED BY
THE PROGRAM THAT THAT SHE'S
RUNNING ANY WAS MACHEL -- TO
PROVIDE SHELTER AND HOUSING FOR
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY IT'S A
NOBLE CAUSE I'D LIKE TO APPLY
THIS LEGISLATURE ABOUT THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BONDS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING LEGISLATION.
THAT YOU ALL HAVE SUPPORTED IT'S
A PRIORITY FOR THIS LEGISLATURE
I THINK THAT WE ALL NEED TO
REMEMBER THAT THE THINGS THAT WE
DO HERE DO IMPACT LIVE SO I
APPLAUD YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK
IT'S IMPORTANT WORK AND I KNOW
THAT THIS BODY.
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
SENATE ARE LOOKING THIS YEAR TO
MAKE IT EVEN MORE -- AFFORDABLE
AND AND ATTAINABLE TO TO HAVE
THAT SAFE PLACE THAT PEOPLE CAN
GO IN AND HAVE AS A HOME.
TODAY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL BOND WHICH AS
YOU KNOW THE VOTERS DID APPROVE
IN THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY PUT
FORTH AND HAS REVIEWED SEVERAL
TIMES.
I'LL JUST GET TO THE CHASE THE
TO THE SHORT CHASE OF IT IS THE
THE THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF ISSUES
SURROUNDING THE PROJECT.
I THINK THAT WE'VE SEEN SOME
CHANGES IN LEADERSHIP THAT THIS
GOVERNOR HAS COMMITTED TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT.
THAT THE PROJECT THAT'S BEEN
MOVING FORWARD IS EMPLOYING OVER
TWO THOUSAND CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WITH MIDDLE CLASS JOBS.
AND HOUSING IS CRITICAL AS IT IS
AS THE GOVERNOR ALSO STATED IS
TIED TO OUR TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM WE HAVE CONGESTION ON
THE ROADS WE HAVE CONGESTION IN
THE SKIES.
WE NEED TO HAVE A HIGH SPEED
RAIL SYSTEM TO MOVE THE JOBS. TO
THE HOUSING CENTERS WITH THERE'S
A CONNECTION AND PEOPLE CAN HAVE
THAT AFFORDABLE -- AND AND A
GOOD QUALITY OF LIFE AFFORDABLE
HOME TO QUALIFY SO AGAIN I
APPLAUD.
YOUR WITNESSES I THINK THEY'RE
DOING TERRIFIC WORK I KNOW THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS SUPPORTED
NOT ONLY SHELTERS FOR WOMEN BUT
FOR SHELTERS FOR FAMILIES AND
PROVIDING THAT AFFORDABLE HEALTH
CARE -- SEES ME AFFORDABLE HOMES --
SO THE PEOPLE CAN BE SAFE AND
OUT OF THE TERM MATIC EXPERIENCE
AND WE ALL APPLAUD YOU FOR FOR
MOVING TO A SAFE ENVIRONMENT AND
PROVIDING THAT SO AGAIN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK IN
PROVIDING A SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR
PEOPLE IN THE SACRAMENTO
COMMUNITY I KNOW THERE'S MANY OF
YOU.
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE TO DO THE
SAME IN THEIR COMMUNITIES THE IN
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE WITH
THE OVERSIGHT OF THE PROGRAM.
THE VOTERS DID ENDORSE THE
PROGRAM AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO
TO BUILDING HIGH SPEED RAIL IT'S
NEEDED FOR OUR STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
OF IN OPPOSITION OF THE AUTHORS
OR HAVE CONCERNS IT'S LIKE TO
ADDRESS.
SEEN ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE.
WELL MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR RIGHT I
ALSO LONG THANK YOU ALSO FOR
BRINGING THIS.
BILL FORWARD IN A HOUSING IT IS
TO THE BIG BIG ISSUE --
SPECIALLY IN MY DISTRICT FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING JUST LIKE THE
OPPOSITION JUST STATE THAT -- WE
HAVE MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED BILLS
ARE MOVING THROUGH THE PROCESS
TO A TRYING TO ADDRESS THESE --
HOUSING ISSUE AND UP.
I ALSO WANT TO SINK TO THE
WITNESSES AND OF YOUNG FAMILIES
WHO.
COME OVER HERE ENTIRE SUPPLY --
BUT UP ARE I'D HATE.
TO YOU KNOW MOVE TO MONEY FROM
TRANSPORTATION TO HOUSING
BECAUSE I FELT THAT.
IS THIS THE TO THE SAME PROBLEM
TO TWO TWO SIDES OF THE SAME
PROBLEM.
WE NEED -- TO AND IMPROVE FOR
TRANSPORTATION SO PEOPLE THAT
LIVE -- CAN'T CAN'T CAN'T.
LIVE OUTSIDE OF THE IT COULD
DROP RICH AREA BE ABLE TO TO TO
COMMUTE. TO TO TO WORK YOU KNOW
SO -- WOULD BE -- OPPOSING THIS
BILL [inaudible]
MR GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN THE
THANK YOU -- TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AS
WELL AS FOR THE WITNESSES AND
THEY'RE VERY EMOTIONAL APPEAL --
FOR HOUSING I JUST WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO GO ON RECORD -- TO BE
ABLE TO STATE THAT -- OBVIOUSLY
HOUSING IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
THAT HOWEVER TO TRY TO SILO
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION TO
WHERE THEY'RE NOT INTEGRATED AND
WORK TOGETHER RATHER THAN
AGAINST EACH OTHER IS NOT
PRODUCTIVE FOR THE WHOLE PICTURE.
AND AS WAS STATED IN TESTIMONY
WHERE WE DO HAVE HOUSING -- I
HAVE RAN SEVERAL HOUSING BILLS
MYSELF AND AND ENJOYED THE THE
BENEFIT OF SUPPORT OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO BUILD A MOVE
CERTAIN HOUSING BILLS FORWARD
THAT HAVE BEEN A PART OF THE THE
PACKAGE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
AND THEN ALSO TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT -- BY CHOOSING ONE I
DIDN'T DENY OR REJECT THE OTHER
I THINK BEING ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT TRANSPORTATION IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT.
AS HOUSING IN MANY INSTANCES AND
THAT HOUSING -- WITHOUT
TRANSPORTATION -- IS IS NOT
REALLY BENEFITING THE HOSTED A
CALIFORNIA'S FAR AS THE QUALITY
OF LIFE AS WELL AS SITUATIONS IN
YOUR VERY INSTANCE SO WITH THAT
SAID -- I AM SUPPORTIVE OF
TRANSPORTATION AND I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF PROJECTS THAT HELP
US MOVE AND TO BE ABLE.
TO CONNECT HOUSING COMMUNITIES
TOGETHER AS WELL AS BEING ABLE
SUPPORT HOUSING IN THE RIGHT
VENUES AND IN THE RIGHT
MECHANISMS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR FROM COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
SOMEWHERE WAS LIKE CLOSE I WOULD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
AND AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS
DAY I UNDERSTAND.
IT'S A TOUGH CALL BECAUSE YOU'RE
FOR HOUSING YOUR FOR AT YOU KNOW
TRANSPORTATION AND THEY ARE ALL
INTER TWINED WHAT I WILL SAY TO
YOU THOUGH IS THAT -- IF THERE
IS NO HOUSING THERE IS NOTHING
TO CONNECT.
TO WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
TRAIN IN A TRAIN BUILT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY DOESN'T HELP
THOSE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
DOESN'T HELP THOSE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE NUMBER ONE IN
POVERTY IN THE NATION WE HAVE
THE MOST NUMBER OF HOMELESS
PEOPLE IN THE NATION.
THAT IS A TRAVESTY AND THIS BILL
LIKE MANY OTHERS FRANKLY TOOK TO
GIVE FULL CREDIT WHERE CREDIT IS
DUE LIKE MANY OTHERS THIS BILL
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
BECAUSE WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO
IGNORE THAT.
RIGHT -- AND I DON'T DISAGREE
WITH YOU THAT TRANSPORTATION IS
A IMPORTANT OBVIOUSLY IT IS BUT
I ALSO DON'T THINK THAT THERE'S
ANYTHING WRONG WITH PUTTING THIS
BACK BEFORE THE VOTERS. TO GIVE
THEM ANOTHER CHANCE TO WEIGH IN
ON THIS -- AND GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THERE HAS BEEN SO MUCH
MEDIA ATTENTION GIVEN TO OUR
HOMELESS SITUATION THAT IS NOT
GETTING BETTER IT IS GETTING
WORSE.
AND THE FACT THAT WE HAVE SUCH A
HIGH NUMBER OF PEOPLE LIVING IN
POVERTY.
I THINK THE VOTERS DESERVE THE
CHANCE TO HAVE THIS PUT BEFORE
THEM AGAIN AND MAKE THEIR
DECISION IT IS IT'S THEIR MONEY
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT APPROVED
THE PROJECT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
CERTAINLY WE SHOULD GIVE THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON THIS
AGAIN -- AND I JUST I THINK WE
OWE IT TO THEM TO DO THAT I
DON'T THINK IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE I
FRANKLY THINK IT'S A BIT
DISRESPECTFUL TO NOT PUT IT
BEFORE THEN GIVEN THE FACT THAT.
THE HOUSING CRISIS HAS GONE ON
FOR SO LONG AND IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE ALL AGREE WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT RIGHT.
SO WITH THAT SAID I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS -- BUT I AM HERE
TO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
A MOTION.
SO I HAVE A A MOTION BY SUMMER
FONG AS SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
BIGELOW -- MS WINDOWS.
I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY.
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT IS AT A
CROSSROADS.
AND I HAVE TOURED COUNTRIES THAT
HAD HAVE HAD.
HIGH SPEED WILL DRAMATICALLY
CHANGE.
THIRD GENERAL THEIR THEIR GDP.
THIRD THEIR ECONOMY THE WHOLE
THE WHOLE HOUSING SITUATION --
AND IT'S BEEN A DRAMATIC
IMPROVEMENT FOR THOSE THOSE
COUNTRIES.
THIS IS THE LARGEST
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AND YES IT'S HAD ITS PROBLEMS.
OF TOWARD THE PROJECT
EXTENSIVELY.
A COUPLE OF TIMES.
AND BEING FROM THE WORLD OF
CONSTRUCTION I SAW ISSUES THAT I
BUT TO THE FRONT FOREFRONT.
OF GOVERNOR GOVERNOR NEWSON IS
LAYER OF NEW VISION -- FOR THE
PROJECT WITH THE PROJECT UP THE
REPORT WE EXPECT AND ON MAY
FIRST.
OF THIS COMMITTEE WILL HOLD A
HEARING AND DIG INTO THE PLAN
LIKE WE HAVE -- WE HAVE BEEN
VERY VERY THOROUGH IN OUR
OVERSIGHT AND OUR CAPACITY -- WE
WILL MAKE SOME TOUGH DECISIONS
ABOUT THE FUTURE THE PROJECT
SOON BUT WE CANNOT JUST PULL THE
PLUG ON IT AND LEAVE A STRANDED.
INVESTMENT -- AND FOR THAT
REASON I'LL BE VOTING NO ON YOUR
BILL TODAY.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER NO FRAZIER NO FONG.
FONG I BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CHIU.
CHIU NOW CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DAILY NOW DALY NOW
DEEP.
HI DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
ADMIN NO GIPSON.
GIPSON NOW GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NO MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
IT HAS SIX WILL LEAVE THE ROLL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS -- SKEWS
ME.
FOR AYE VOTES SIX KNOWS LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN UP TO YOUR TO YOUR
WITNESS.
I SERVE ON THE SUB ONE OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE I'D
LOVE TO SEE YOUR TESTIMONY THERE.
I THINK THAT THE APPROPRIATE
PLACE THANK YOU.
SO WE WILL MISTER CELIS.
THAT SIR AB SIX THIRTY FOUR
MISTER SAUSAGE.
WHILE YOU'RE GETTING READY
MISTER -- CELLS WILL GO AHEAD
AND TAKE UP CONCERT CALENDAR.
BUT SECRETARY.
ALWAYS SO WE DO HAVE A MEASURES
ON CONSENT FILE ITEM. ONE A. B.
C.'S TWO FIVE NINE CALDERON FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB THIRTEEN
TEN RADIUS.
FILE ITEM NINE SIXTEEN THIRTY
THREE GRAYSON.
FILE ITEM TEN A. B. SIXTEEN
SEVENTY ONE BERMAN.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AC OR FORTY
FOUR GALLEY WE HAD A FIRST AND A
SECOND WHOSE FIRST THE SECOND.
GIPSON AND FONG FIRST AND SECOND --
WE MET OF SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FRAZIER [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DAILY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
I CONSENT KILLERS OUT.
WE ROLLED IN FRANCE A MEMBERS
MISTER.
CELIS READY PROCEED YES
LEGISLATURE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE PRESENT BEFORE YOU SIMPLY
BILL.
SIX THIRTY FOUR I WHICH I THINK
IS A SIMPLE MEASURE JUST ALLOWS
US TO NAME AROUND ABOUT A
CATEGORY OF STATE HIGHWAY
FACILITIES.
THAT COULD BE DAY BY THE
LEGISLATURE OTHER BENEFITS OF
ROUNDABOUTS COMPARED TO
TRADITIONAL AT INTERSECTIONS ARE
WELL DOCUMENTED THESE A STATIC
DESIGNS ARE ENCOURAGED BY THE
GUY AND BY THE GUY THAT CALTRANS
USES WHEN DESIGNING ROUND ABOUT.
A MEMORIAL ROUNDABOUTS -- CAN
ALSO BE FOUND THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES.
THERE HAVE BEEN NO REPORTED
ISSUES IN MASSACHUSETTS THE
COMMUNITY OF FREETOWN.
FOUGHT TO CREATE A WRAP AROUND
ABOUT IT IN THE TORY ASLI
DANGEROUS FOUR WAY INTERSECTION.
AND WORK WITH THE STATE AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS TO DEDICATE THAT
ROUND ABOUT IN HONOR.
OF NAVY PETTY OFFICER CLASS MEN
THAT TYLER TRAY HAND WHO WAS
KILLED WHILE ON DUTY IN IRAQ.
THERE'S ANOTHER MEMORIAL ROUND
ABOUT WHICH WAS BROUGHT ABOUT --
IN AN ENTIRELY ANOTHER CITY IN
BEAVERTON OREGON AND THAT WAS
DEDICATED TO ANOTHER SOLDIER.
AND ANDREW KELLER ANOTHER ROUND
ABOUT HAPPENED IN TEXAS --
NAMING BAYTOWN TEXAS IS AROUND
ABOUT DEDICATED TO MEXICAN
AMERICAN WAR GENERAL SAM HOUSTON.
AND WAR WAR ONE MEMORIAL ON THE
CENTRAL ISLAND AROUND ABOUT AND
BLADENSBURG MARYLAND DEDICATED
TO FIFTY YOUNG MEN WHO WERE
KILLED IN FRANCE AROUND ABOUT
WAS DEDICATED TO A PIONEER
FAMILY.
IN UTAH.
EVEN IN KENTUCKY THERE WAS ONE
NAMED AFTER SECRETARY.
SO THE NAMING OF ROUNDABOUTS IS
ACTUALLY SOMETHING THAT OCCURS
IN FORTY EIGHT OF THE OTHER
STATES SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD
LOVE TO DO HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE DID A LITTLE BIT OF RESEARCH
ON THIS AND BACK IN -- NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSED THROUGH CHAPTER FIVE
SEVENTY NINE THE NAMING OF
HIGHWAY BRIDGES WERE JUST
LOOKING TO ADD ROUNDABOUTS TO
THAT LANGUAGE.
AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CELLS ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES YOU BROUGHT
FORWARD TURNED TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL.
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON THAT LIST
RIGHT NOW AND THERE'S A COUPLE
OF THEM THAT I JUST LEFT IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE OKAY.
SO ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY.
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE -- TO TESTIFIED OPPOSITION
OR CHAU CONCERNS WITH THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE I ANY -- QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE OF OF THE
AUTHOR.
I THINK ANOTHER QUESTION OUR
DRESSER QUESTION IN MY CLOTHES.
SO -- MISTER CELIS LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE GONNA GET THAT
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO WE WENT AROUND
AROUND.
ON THIS ISSUE WITH CALTRANS ON
THE LOCALS AND ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
THIRTY FOUR WAS A WAY THAT.
WE LOOK TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
SO THANK YOU WASN'T TRYING TO GO
ABOUT IT IN AROUND ABOUT HUESO
APPRECIATE.
OTHER QUESTIONS THAT YOU WERE
THINKING OF BUT IT AND ASKING
YOU WERE SO GRACIOUS TO DO THAT
SORT OF RESPECTFULLY SCREWDRIVER.
WE DON'T LOSE YOUR DAY JOB -- SO --
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
HAVEN'T HEARD ONE YET.
WE HAVE A MOVIE BUT MR RACES
SECOND BY MISTER GIBSON -- THANK
YOU SO MEMBER CELLS FOR COMING.
TODAY -- IN A ROUND ABOUT WAY.
PERSONALLY I BELIEVE WE SHOULD
LEAVE THE HIGHWAY DECISION A
TRAFFIC SAFETY DECISIONS TO THE
EXPERTS.
I DO NOT THINK IT'S A GOOD
PRACTICE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
DICTATE WHAT SHOULD BE INCLUDED
IN THE TRAFFIC CONTROL DEVICE
MANUAL [inaudible]
FURTHERMORE.
THERE ARE ABOUT SIXTEEN THOUSAND
OPPORTUNITIES TO MEMORIALIZE
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE NEED
TO START ADDING ROUNDABOUTSWHEN
IT'S SUCH A CONFUSING ISSUE
ALREADY FOR THE PUBLIC.
THEREFORE I WILL NOT BE.
VOTING. FOR YOU BUT BILL TODAY.
BUT OUT OF RESPECT TO WILL BE
VOTING.
THANK YOU PUSH IT UP.
BUT OF SECRETARY CALLED.
THE MOTION IS YOUR PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
SURE.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DAILY.
DALY AYE DEEP [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
IT IS FIVE EYES WILL LEAVE OF
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR VISITING.
SO OUR NEXT.
AUTHOR IS A AB NINE NINE EIGHT
YOUR CURRENT [inaudible]
YOUR TODAY.
NOT HERE WILL MOVE ON TO US AB
ELEVEN SIXTY SEVEN MR MATHIS
PLEASE PROCEED. TO THE DICE.
THE AFTERNOON PLEASE -- SO WHEN
YOU READY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT.
AB.
ELEVEN SIXTY SEVEN THIS MEASURE
WOULD SERVE [inaudible]
WOULD SEVER.
THE HIGH SPEED ROLES FUNDING.
FROM GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND.
MEMBERS WE ARE ALL AWARE OF THE
RECENT DEVELOPMENTS WITH THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THE PROJECT HAS
FAILED TO ACCOMPLISH EVEN COME
CLOSE TO ACCOMPLISHING VOTER
INTENT.
MISTER CHAIR EVEN.
YOU HAVE STATED THAT THE
AUTHORITY.
NEEDS INCREASED ACCOUNTABILITY
AND OVERSIGHT.
AND I APPLAUD YOUR WORK IN
LEADERSHIP ON TRYING TO BRING
THE RELIC FORTY INTO COMPLIANCE.
HOWEVER IS BECOME FAR TOO
APPARENT THE MORE TIME WILL BE
NEEDED TO FIX THE AUTHORITY.
IF.
IT EVEN CAN BE FIXED.
AS SUCH WE ALL NEED TO LOOK AT
ITS CURRENT FUNDING SOURCE AND
SEE IF.
THE AUTHORITY DESERVES THESE
FUNDS.
THE QUESTION I MUST GAS.
WHAT ARE WE REALLY FUNDING?
MISTER CHAIR.
YOU AGAIN RECOGNIZE THE FLAWED
DECISION MAKING AND THAT POOR
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT BY THE
AUTHORITY HAS LED TO BILLIONS.
AND COST OVERRUNS AND DELAYS.
ALL OF THIS SPELLS WASTED
TAXPAYER DOLLARS IN THE BILLIONS.
AGAIN I ASK WHAT ARE WE REALLY
PAYING.
FOR I HAVE COME TO THE
UNDERSTANDING.
THAT WE ARE WASTING AN R. G. G.
R. F. MONIES.
ON THIS BOONDOGGLE OF A PROJECT
[inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
I DIDN'T SUPPORT THE CAP AND
TRADE REVISION.
SO WE COULD THROW THE MONEY AWAY.
INSTEAD I'D LIKE TO SEVER
FUNDING FROM THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND SEND IT TO CAL FIRE.
WHERE IT'LL ACTUALLY BE PUT TO
GOOD USE?
AS WE ARE ALL TO AWARE MASSIVE
AND DEVASTATING WILDFIRES ARE
BECOMING ALL TOO COMMON IN OUR
STATE.
SADLY IT IS RESULTED.
IN AN UNACCEPTABLE LOSS OF LIFE.
A LARGE CONTRIBUTE FACTOR. TO
THIS DISASTER SITUATION IS FOUND
WITHIN OUR FOREST TODAY.
WE HAVE A MASS PROBLEM WITH ARE
FORCED HEALTH.
AND COMPLACENCY IS NOT MAKING IT
ANY BETTER.
AND ONLY WORSE.
SIMPLY PUT.
LEAVING OUR FORCE MANAGEMENT
[inaudible]
ON MANAGED.
IS NO LONGER A SAFE OPTION.
WE CAN AND MUST DO A BETTER JOB.
OF PROTECTING BOTH THE FOREST
AND THE COMMUNITIES OF THE URBAN
WILDLAND INTERFACE. ONE WAY THAT
WE CAN ACCOMPLISH THIS.
IS BY ADDICT QUICK LEE FUNDING
CAL FIRE.
I AM VERY GRATEFUL TO SEE THE
GOVERNOR NEWSOME RECOGNIZES THAT
NEED. TO CLEAR OUT DEAD TREES BY
DECLARING A STATE OF EMERGENCY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AHEAD OF THE COMING FIRE SEASON.
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN ZERO FIVE ONE
NINE CREWS ARE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO REDUCING FIRE
FUELS THAT ARE STILL PLAGUING
OUR COMMUNITIES TODAY. ONE SUCH
WAY THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
AND PREVENT FUTURE EMERGENCIES.
AS THROUGH THE SUPPLEMENT TOLL
FUNDING. TO CAL FIRE FUND WITHIN
AB.
ELEVEN SIXTY SEVEN WITH THE
FUNDING WE CAN HIRE MORE
FIREFIGHTERS AND PURCHASE NEW
EQUIPMENT.
WE CAN BETTER PROTECT OUR BRAVE
FIREFIGHTERS AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
ALSO I'M INCLUDED A PROVISION
WHICH WOULD HELP FIREFIGHTERS
WHO HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES WHAT
DEPLOYED TO REBUILD AND REGAIN A
SENSE OF NORMALCY.
MEMBERS THIS FUNDING FOR CAL
FIRE IS LONG OVERDUE.
I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME TODAY.
AND SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE TO
ENSURE ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR CAL
FIRE [inaudible]
I ASK.
YOU TO JOIN.
OUR GOVERNOR IN RECOGNIZING.
THIS STATE OF EMERGENCY THAT WE
ARE AN BUT I ASK YOU FOR YOUR
AYE VOTES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS.
WITH THIS PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND WE REPRESENT PLEASE.
COURSE MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WILL FOR THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN SIXTY SEVEN HERE TODAY
AND AS THAT MISTER MATHIS NOTED --
ADDITIONAL MONEY TO FIGHT
WILDFIRES IS VERY MUCH NEEDED WE
KNOW EIGHTY NINE A ONE LAST YEAR
DEVOTED ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS --
TO DO BRUSH ACCORDING TO DO
THINGS LIKE TREE REMOVAL BUT
CLEARLY AND I THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S EMERGENCY DECLARATION
MAKES GOOD NOTE OF THIS THAT
MONEY WAS NOT SUFFICIENT AND
MORE IS NEEDED.
THE WHOLE POINT OF CAP AND TRADE
MEMBERS IS TO FIGHT EMISSIONS
AND PROMOTE EMISSION REDUCTIONS
AND WHAT BETTER WAY TO DO THAT.
THAN -- TO YOU KNOW INSURE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS --
THROUGH PUTTING OUT WILD FIRES
FASTER AND ENSURING THAT THEY
DON'T EVEN HAPPENED AT ALL
CONTINUES TO OCCUR -- I THINK
THAT'S INTO A COMPLETELY
APPROPRIATE USE OF CAP AND TRADE
DOLLARS AND CERTAINLY MORE.
EFFICIENT AND BETTER THAN HIGH
SPEED RAIL THERE WAS TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN REPORT MISTER
CHAIRMAN DONE BY.
THE REASON FOUNDATION ON HIGH
SPEED RAIL THAT MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT A STATE -- HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO AND
SAN DIEGO WILL ROOM WILL RESULT
IN A NET INCREASE OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS -- NOW YOU LOOK AT
THE WILD FIRES FROM LAST YEAR
SIXTY EIGHT MILLION TIMES.
OF GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AS A
RESULT OF THESE FIRES CARBON
EMISSIONS -- THAT'S ROUGHLY THE
AMOUNT OF ENERGY THAT IT TAKES
TO GENERATE ALL THE ELECTRICITY
IN THE STATE FOR ONE YEAR.
IT SEEMS LIKE MORE MONEY FOR
FIREFIGHTERS MORE MONEY FOR
BRUSH REMOVAL MORE MONEY FOR
THESE THINGS IS A COMPLETELY
WONDERFUL USED TO CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS WE ASK THE MONEY WOULD GO
THERE AND WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE.
THANKS SIR ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC FEEL LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OR SHARE CONCERNS
WITH AUTHORS.
SO YOUR NAME WHO YOU'RE
REPRESENTING PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN KEITH DONE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL FARMWORKERS ROLES THE
CESSATION CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
TRAINS.
LET'S LET'S GET ONE THING OUT OF
THE OPEN EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU
INCLUDING EVERYONE YOUR
COLLEAGUES IN THIS BUILDING
WANTS TO SEE FIRE FIGHTING --
FUNDED WE WANT TO STOP FOR AS
FAR AS TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT'S
REALISTIC.
I AM A RESIDENT -- GREW UP IN
BI<c.cyan> COUNTY THE HOME THAT I</c>
RAISE MY DAUGHTER IN BURNED TO
THE GROUND IN THE CAMP FIRE WE
ALL HAVE EXPERIENCED DEVASTATING
EFFECTS OF WILDFIRES LIVING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO MAKE IT A PRIORITY AND TO
FUND OUR FIRST RESPONDERS.
IT'S A PRIORITY FOR YOU WE ALL
KNOW IT AND IT'S PRIORITY FOR US
NOW LET'S TALK ABOUT OUR
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROGRAM AS
WE'VE ALL HAVE STIPULATED HAS
HAD A NUMBER OF ISSUES THIS
GOVERNOR.
GOING FORWARD HAS INSTITUTED A
NEW LEADERSHIP THIS BODY AS WELL
AS YOUR COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE
HAVE HELD NUMEROUS OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO.
AS MENTIONED -- AFTER THEIR
REPORT COMES OUT AT THE END OF
MAY WE ARE BUILDING AND
INVESTING IN A POLICY OF
REDUCING OUR CLIMATE FOOTPRINT
THE PART OF THAT IS A
TRANSFORMATIVE INNOVATIVE.
RAIL SYSTEM THAT AGAIN HAS HAD
SOME MISSTEPS WE ALL ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT BUT THERE'S BEEN A
COMMITMENT FROM THIS NEW
ADMINISTRATION. TO MOVE FORWARD
I ALSO APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR AND
HIS EMERGENCY DECLARATION AND
PUTTING RESOURCES -- TO TO FIGHT.
A CATASTROPHIC FIRES INTO
ADDRESS ONE OF THE ISSUES WHICH
IS DEAD AND DYING TREES -- HE IS
CLEARLY MADE THAT A PRIORITY I
KNOW THAT EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU HAVE DONE SO AS WELL SO WE
CAN DO BOTH WE DO DO BOTH
CALIFORNIA IS AN INNOVATIVE
STATE WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE.
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF BECAUSE
THESE CATASTROPHIC FIRES ONE OF
WHICH IS CLIMATE CHANGE.
WHICH THE HIGH SPEED RAIL IS
DESIGNED TO REDUCE SET FOOT
PRINT DOESN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT
NO YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE SYSTEM
UP AND RUNNING. TO GET PEOPLE
OUT OF THEIR VEHICLES AND ON TO
THE SYSTEM SO AGAIN I APPRECIATE
THE EFFORT TO FULLY FUND CAL
FIRE AND TO REDUCE -- THE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES HERE
STATE I ALWAYS APPRECIATE MR
WALLS REFERENCE OF REPORTS --
THERE'S A FEW OTHER REPORTS THAT
WE CAN GET INTO AND HAVE A
HEARTY DEBATE ON SOME DAY WE'RE
GOING TO BE ON THE SAME SIDE OF
AN ISSUE.
OTHER THAN THAT I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY AT ALL.
OPPOSITION.
TO EXPLICIT YOUR NAME IN THE
REPRESENT.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
CATHERINE GARCIA WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA.
WE OPPOSE ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN WHICH WOULD DIVERT
FUNDING FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
FROM.
REDUCTION FUND TO SUPPORT THE
CLEARING OF TREES AND THE
CONSTRUCTION OF HOMES NEITHER OF
THESE YEAR USES ENSURE AND NEXUS
BETWEEN THE EXPENDITURE AND THE
NEED TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
THE PROGRAM IS PROMOTED IN AB
ELEVEN SIXTY SEVEN WOULD NOT
DIRECTLY REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN THE NEAR TERM.
NOR WOULD THEY INSURE REDUCTIONS
OVER TIME.
AN UNDERLYING ASSUMPTION OF TE
BILL'S EXPENDITURE PROPOSAL IS
THAT FOREST SUFFERING FROM
BEETLE INFESTATION AND DROUGHT
IMPACTS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
RECENT MEGA FIRES.
THAT HAVE DOES DEVASTATED SANTA
ROSA PARADISE AND OTHER
POPULATED PARTS THE STATE THIS
ASSUMPTION IS FAULTY AND IS
BEING USED THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL TO PUSH MEASURES THAT
ARE HARMFUL FOR THE FOREST
ECOSYSTEM.
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND IS A VALUABLE MECHANISM FOR
ACHIEVING CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
GOALS.
THE STATE MUST ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDING SUPPORT SOLUTIONS THAT
ARE PROVEN AND EFFECTIVE IN
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN THE NEAR TERM THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF PUBLICLY TO TESTIFY
IN A POSITION -- SURE CONCERNS
OF AUTHORS BILL.
SINGLE BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE SEEING NONE
MISTER MATHIS WHICH LIKE CLOSE
ABSOLUTELY MUST SHARE.
MEMBERS ONE I THINK THE SIERRA
CLUB NEEDS -- TO REDEFINE WHAT
TIME IT CHANGES AND ACTUALLY
FULLY LOOK AT THE BILLS -- WE'VE
GOT TO DO SOMETHING WITH THE
FORCE IT'S CLEAR WITH THE
GOVERNOR STATE OF EMERGENCY.
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND.
WAS DESIGNED. TO ADDRESS.
THIS PROBLEM THIS PROBLEM OF A
MEN'S.
IN THESE GASES THAT ARE
DESTROYING OUR AIR QUALITY.
THE FIRES ARE THE NUMBER ONE
THING.
IF YOU'RE A MEMBER THAT'S BEEN
AROUND A FIRE IF YOU'VE SEEN IT
RAIN ASH UPON FAMILIES HOMES.
AND IT GOES FAR BEYOND JUST THE
IDEA OF A BAD AIR DAY
[inaudible]
THESE FIRES.
CAN BE PREVENTED.
WE CAN USE THESE MONIES FOR WHAT
THEY OUGHT TO BE USED.
FOR IN INTEL THE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
GETS IN GEAR AND ACTUALLY SHOWS
THAT IT'S A VIABLE PROJECT.
WE CAN USE THESE FUNDS WERE
THERE DESPERATELY NEEDED I ASK
YOU FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS I
HAVEN'T HEARD IN MOTION AT WHO
WASH MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BIGELOW -- MISTER MATHIS I WON'T
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
WE'VE HAD TWO BILLS BEFORE US
TODAY TO TAKE STATE FUNDING AWAY
FROM THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT.
AS I'VE SAID IN THE PREVIOUS
BILL THIS COMMITTEE WILL HOLD A
HEARING ON GOVERNOR NEWSOM'SNEW
VISION FOR THE PROJECT.
AND THE PROJECT UPDATE OF THE
REPORT IN [inaudible]
IN MAY.
I WILL KNOW WE HAVE SOME TOUGH
DECISIONS TO MAKE.
ABOUT THE FUTURE THE PROJECTS
AND THAT SOONER THAN LATER.
BUT WE NEED BUT WE CANNOT JUST
PULL THE PLUG OR INVESTMENT THAT.
HAS PUT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AT
IN -- AN ECONOMY.
AND A WE'LL TELL YOU OF THE
TOURING THAT I'VE DONE IN SOME
OF THE WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION REPLACING THE
CHAIRMAN.
OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
WAS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
IN DOING SO I AM FIRMLY
BELIEVING THAT WE CAN MAKE THIS
PROJECT WORK WITH COVER NEWSOM'S.
NEW VISION.
AND FOR THIS THAT REASONABLY
VOTING ON YOUR BILL TODAY.
A MAP SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
FRAZIER [inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
WITH THE LOAD.
NO ABSOLUTELY NO NO [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible] FIVE FONG I
AGUIAR-CURRY NO [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY NOW [inaudible]
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY.
DALY NOW DAVE.
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN.
NO FRIEDMAN NOW.
GIPSON.
GIPSON NOW [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
MEDINA.
IS THERE IN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
THAT HAS SO.
IS A FOUR EYES FOR FRIES WE ROLL
OPEN FOR ABSOLUTE RESPECT HIM AS
MATHIS MISTER LIKE TO ASK FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION IT'S A
PROGRAM AT THE TIME WE CAN GIVE
YOU RECONSIDERATION.
IS GRANTED SAME RESULT.
I THANK YOU.
SOON -- WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
AB [inaudible]
TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN THIS
.
MR CHAD THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
THE COMMITTEE STAFF THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS -- BILL IN
THE ANALYSIS.
YOU KNOW I'M HERE THIS AFTERNOON
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
SIXTY SEVEN WHICH IS LEGISLATION
SEEKING TO UPDATE CALIFORNIA
SUCCESSFUL.
PROVISIONAL LICENSING PROGRAM
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS PDL.
NOW I FOR ONE THING MY FRIEND
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER -- BECAUSE THIS
LEGISLATION -- AB TWELVE SIXTY
SEVEN MAY HAVE ROBERT RIVAS AS
THE AUTHOR -- BUT THIS BILL --
CERTAINLY -- THIS IDEA IS NOT
NEW -- FOR SEVERAL YEARS
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER HAS PROVIDED
INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP -- ON THIS
ISSUE.
I AND WITH HIS HELP HIS GUIDANCE
I BELIEVE WE WERE WE ARE ON OUR
WAY TO MAKING THE CHANGES -- TO
HAVING THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WILL ULTIMATELY SAVE YOUNG
DRIVERS LIVES SO FOR THAT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
RECENTLY PUBLISHED STUDY IN THE
NEW ENGLAND JOURNAL OF MEDICINE
AND ACCORDING TO THE DATA FROM
THE US.
THE CENTERS -- FOR THE DISEASE
CONTROL PREVENTION.
THE MAJOR CAUSE OF DEATH IN
CHILDREN AGED ONE TO NINETEEN IN
THE UNITED STATES IS NOT CANCER.
OR ANOTHER MEDICAL CONDITION
IT'S INJURY.
INJURY RELATED TO DEATH SUCH AS
TRAFFIC ACCIDENT FATALITIES.
DRUG OVERDOSES HOMICIDES AND
SUICIDES.
BUT IT'S TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS THAT
OVERWHELMINGLY ACCOUNT. FOR A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF THOSE
UNINTENDED INJURY DEATHS OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE.
CALIFORNIA IS NO EXCEPTION.
ACCORDING TO THE CENTER FOR
DISEASE FOR THE THE DISEASE
CONTROL AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH.
DRIVER INVOLVED ACCIDENTS ARE
THE LEADING CAUSE OF INJURY AND
DEATH OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
STATE.
THE DATA IS CRYSTAL CLEAR AND
ACCORDING TO SEVERAL SUBJECT
AREA EXPERTS FROM PUBLIC SAFETY.
HEALTH CARE PUBLIC HEALTH.
INSURANCE COMPANIES YOUTH
ADVOCATES SEVERAL FACTORS HAVE
LED AND WILL CONTINUE TO LEAD.
IN A DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
YOUNG PEOPLE INVOLVED IN MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCIDENTS.
AND AMONG THOSE ARE.
AMONG THOSE FACTORS IMMATURITY.
LACK OF DRIVING EXPERIENCE NIGHT
DRIVING.
DRIVING WITH OTHER TEEN
PASSENGERS.
THE PERVASIVENESS OF CELL PHONE
USE WHILE DRIVING.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS DISTRACTED --
DRIVING.
AND FINALLY TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN A LIBERTY MUTUAL STUDY
FOUND THAT IN ADDITION TO ALL
THESE FACTORS.
OLDER TEENAGERS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO ENGAGE AND DANGEROUS
BEHAVIORS WHILE BEHIND THE WHEEL
[inaudible]
FINALLY.
SO WHEN WE DATE BACK TO THE MID
NINETEEN NINETIES.
THE STATE'S BEGAN TO ENACT A
GRADUATED DRIVER'S LICENSE LAWS
HELLO I KNOW THAT AS THE GDL.
THEY DID THIS TO HELP CONTROL
THE PROBLEM RELATED TO YOUTH
RELATED INJURY ACCIDENTS.
AND TO DATE EVERY SINGLE STATE
IN THIS COUNTRY HAS SOME KIND OF
GDL LAW.
AND HERE CALIFORNIA OUR VERSION
OF THE G. D. L. IS KNOWN AS THE
PDL THE PROVISIONAL DRIVER'S
LICENSE PROGRAM.
AND SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
PDL REQUIREMENTS CONSIST OF A
RIGOROUS LEARNING PERIOD -- AND
THAT'S DONE.
BEFORE GRANT TO YOUNG PEOPLE
BETWEEN SIX TO EIGHTEEN YEARS
OLD WITH A DRIVER'S LICENSE THAT
CONTAINS FULL PRIVILEGES.
AND SO THE LICENSEE PROCESS IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDES THREE STAGES
THE FIRST IS A LEARNER'S PERMIT.
STAGE TWO IS A PROVISIONAL
LICENSE AND STAGE THREE IS A
FULL LICENSE.
AND CALIFORNIA'S BL PROGRAM HAS
SAVED LIVES.
AND HAS HAD A REMARKABLE IMPACT
ON REDUCING THE NUMBER OF YOUNG
DRIVER BECAUSE VEHICLE ACCIDENTS.
RESEARCH HAS SUGGESTED THAT
YOUNG DRIVERS WHO CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PL PROGRAM
HAVE 55% FEWER FATAL CRASHES.
THE NOVICE EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
YEAR OLD DRIVERS WHO CHOOSE TO
WAIT AND BYPASS THE PDL PROGRAM
ALTOGETHER.
AND TODAY AT LEAST ONE THREE
DRIVERS WICKS INTEL AFTER
TURNING AGE EIGHTEEN TO GET A
LICENSE. TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
OUR STATE STRATEGIC HIGHWAY
SAFETY PLAN.
RECOMMENDS EXTENDING THE PDL.
PROGRAM TO THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE
THUS COVERING EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
AND TWENTY YEAR OLDS.
AND IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT THIS
BILL.
FOLLOWS THIS RECOMMENDATION.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT THIS
BILL TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN AB
TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN CRATE A FAST
TRACK PDL PROGRAM FOR THIS NEW
AGE GROUP.
AND TO EMPHASIZE EACH PDL STAGES
SHORTEN THE LEARNER'S PERMIT
PHASE IS SIXTY DAYS NOT SIX
MONTHS.
THE PROVISIONAL LICENSE PHASES
SIX MONTHS NOT TWELVE MONTHS.
AND FINALLY I WANT TO BRIEFLY
COMMENT ON THE BILL ANALYSIS
PREPARED BY COMMITTEE STAFF THE
PART OF THE ANALYSIS THAT
CORRECTLY POINTS OUT THAT THE
DMV HAS FINANCIAL CHALLENGES.
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES THAT AB
TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN TOOK INTO
ACCOUNT.
AND I'M PROUD THAT THIS BILL
CONTAINS COST.
BY PROVIDING THE MEANS TO PAY
FOR ALL SUCH BUDGET INCREASES
DUE TO THIS PDF EXTENSION.
THIS IS MADE POSSIBLE IN THIS
BILL BY THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THE DMB AND DRIVER EDUCATION
SCHOOLS.
ALSO I SHOULD SAY THAT I
STRONGLY STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORT TO REINVENT
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
THE DMV'S CHRONIC MISMANAGEMENT
HAS BEEN WELL DOCUMENTED.
BUT IN NO WAY IN NO WAY.
SHOULD THIS PRIOR MISMANAGEMENT
OF THE DMV IMPEDE GOOD POLICY
CHANGES.
CHANGES THAT WILL HELP SAVE
YOUNG WIVES AND MAKE OUR STREETS
MAKE OUR HIGHWAYS A SAFER PLACE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
IN SO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE HERE WITH ME I HAVE
THREE WITNESSES AND I WILL ALLOW
THEM TO INTRODUCE HIMSELF
BECAUSE I WILL JUST PUT YOUR
THEIR NAMES I'M SURE SEVERELY.
THANK YOU MISTER PLEASE PROCEED
THE HI.
MY NAME IS STEVE BERYL AND I'M
THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
CHILDREN'S SAFETY AND HEALTH.
AND WHEN THE LEAD STAFF PEOPLE
IN THIS WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS -- ALONG WITH -- THE CHAIR
AND THE AUTHOR FOR A LONG TIME
NOW -- IT'S A LONG TIME COMING
I'M ALSO HERE -- ALSO ON ON A ON
BEHALF OF IMPACTING DRIVERS
WHICH IS -- THE OTHER CO AUTHOR
OF THE OF THE BILL AND THEY
COULDN'T BE HERE WE HAVE A MAJOR
EVENT ON THIS ISSUE ON WEDNESDAY --
NATIONAL EVENT -- BY AM JOINED
HERE AT THE TABLE WITH KATHY
BARRANCA LETTER INTRODUCED
HERSELF SHE'S A CO CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA UNINTENTIONAL INJURY
PREVENTION STRATEGIC PLAN
PROJECT WE TRY TO GET A LONGER
NAME FOR THAT.
PROJECT BUT WE COULDN'T GET
ENOUGH WORDS -- AND WHAT THAT
PROJECT IS IS TO TRY TO END
UNINTENTIONAL INJURY AS A
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IN
HOSPITALIZATION OF OUR CHILDREN
UP THROUGH THE AGE OF NINETEEN
THERE ARE EIGHT LEADING CAUSES
OF DEATH THAT TAKE THE LIVES AND
HOSPITALIZED WITH SEVERE
INJURIES OUR CHILDREN.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
TEEN DRIVER INVOLVED CRASHES AND
YOUTH DRIVER INVOLVED CRASHES IS
BY FAR THE LEADING CAUSE IF
WE'RE EVER GOING TO GET THE
UNINTENTIONAL INJURY NOT TO BE
THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IN
HOSPITALIZATION.
WE HAVE TO SOLVE THIS ISSUE
FIRST AS THE AUTHOR HAS SO LAID
OUT SO ELOQUENTLY THE COMPONENTS
OF THIS AND IT IS IT SOMETHING
THAT YOU IF THIS BILL PASSES AND
WHEN IT PASSES. 55% REDUCTION ON
TEEN DRIVER CAUSED CRASH
FATALITIES WILL TAKE PLACE YOU
LITERALLY ARE GOING TO BE VOTING
ON SOMETHING THAT LITERALLY WILL
KEEP HUNDREDS OF TEENS ALIVE
EVERY YEAR.
I'M ONLY GOING TO CALM IT GETS
THESE ARE THE AUTHORS ALREADY
COMMENTED ON A NUMBER OF
COMPONENTS ALL I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY ON TECHNICAL ISSUES.
BUT THERE ARE TWO ISSUES THAT
ARE WANTED JUST KIND OF
CRYSTALLIZED.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT EVERY YEAR
IN CALIFORNIA.
A THIRD OF A HIGH SCHOOL IS
KILLED EVERY YEAR IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE GDL
COVERING THIS FULL AGE GROUP.
A THIRD OF A HIGH SCHOOL DIES
EVERY YEAR AND FAR MORE ARE
HOSPITALIZED.
THE OTHER THING THAT THIS BILL
HAS ACCOMPLISHED IS NEGOTIATING
OVER TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
THE CHANGES THAT THIS BILL
BRINGS ABOUT IS PAID.
FOR THROUGH THE FEES THAT ARE
ALREADY A RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THE DMV IN OUR LICENSE DRIVER
EDUCATION SCHOOL SO THERE'S
PLENTY OF MONEY TO PAY FOR THE
PROGRAM.
THIS IS NOT A NEW PROGRAM DMV
DOES THIS IS BEEN COMING THEY
WERE THE SIGNATORY ON THE
STRATEGIC HIGHWAY SAFETY PLAN.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE A BIG
LIFT FOR THEM TO CHANGE THIS IT
WILL TAKE SOME WORK BUT THIS IS
NOT THE THING THAT'S GOING TO
KEEP.
THE DMV FROM BECOMING A SOUND
AND NON CHALLENGED PLACE.
THEY HAVE ENOUGH MONEY IN THIS
BILL.
AND IT'S A PROGRAM THAT IS BEEN
ON THE LANDSCAPE FOR A LONG TIME
THERE WILL BE SOME CHANGES BUT
IT'S JUST AN AGE CHANGE THAT WE
HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO STRESS
IS THAT A LOT OF MISCONCEPTIONS
ABOUT WHEN A DRIVER HAS A
PROVISIONAL LICENSE AND AS THE
AUTHOR POINTED OUT WE HAVE
SHORTENED THAT PROVISIONAL
LICENSE FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
AND TWENTY YEAR OLDS TO SIX
MONTHS.
YOU CAN DRIVE TO WORK YOU CAN
DRIVE TO SCHOOL YOU CAN ALL YOUR
FAMILY MEMBERS AROUND YOU CAN
DRIVE YOURSELF TO THE IF YOU'RE
A FARM WORKER GOING TO A DAIRY
FARM AT THREE IN THE MORNING.
YOU CAN DO THAT THAT HAS NEVER
BEEN BLOCKED BY THE GDL PROGRAM.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO SCHOOL IN THE
URBAN AREAS YOU CAN DO THAT WE
JUST FOR THOSE SIX MONTHS UNTIL
YOU'RE A VERY SAFE EXPERIENCED
DRIVER WE DON'T WANT YOU DOING.
THE THINGS THAT BECAUSE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE FORENSICS OF THESE
ACCIDENTS GETS DISTRACTED
DRIVING IS THE BIGGEST CAUSE OF
THE ACCIDENT THAT KILLED THESE
KIDS.
AND KILL THE YOUNG PEOPLE AND SO
THOSE THINGS ARE RESTRICTED FOR
SIX MONTHS BUT YOU CAN TRY TO
WORK YOU CAN DO ALL THAT AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE THINK THAT -- IF
YOU HAVE THIS YOU CAN'T YOU
CAN'T DO THAT.
SO I'M GONNA JUST STOP WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IF
YOU HAVE ANY IT'S NOT A NEW
ISSUE IS THE AUTHOR POINTED OUT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS KATHY
WEARING CAN NOT GIVEN THAT FAST --
MOTION AND SECOND ALL JUST BE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THAT'S VERY STUDIOUS.
GET TO WORK WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HERE TO REGISTER OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU WITHOUT.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
FEEL LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU REPRESENT
CAN STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF ALL STATE INSURANCE IN
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT.
MATIC IN ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
WITH SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
KEVIN ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
NATIONWIDE IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT THE AUTHORS BILL.
SAYING NO TO ANY MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY OR SHARE CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
THIS FREEDOM.
THANK YOU I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE ADVOCATES AND I DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S REALLY A A POINT OR
QUESTION.
BUT YOU WERE COMPARING -- FOR
PEOPLE WHO GO THROUGH THE
PROGRAM -- AND THEIR ACCIDENT
RATES TO PEOPLE WHO DON'T GO TO
THE PROGRAM AND THEIR ACCIDENT
RATES.
SO IF I'M CORRECT IN THE WAY
THESE PRO THIS PROGRAM WORKS IS
PEOPLE ARE BASICALLY OPTING IN --
BY GETTING THEIR LICENSE AT A
CERTAIN AGE CORRECT SO YOU HAVE
A GROUP THAT'S OPTING INTO THE
PROGRAM AS OPPOSED TO A GROUP
THAT'S NOT.
CURRENTLY OUR PROGRAM ONLY GOES
TO AGE.
EIGHTEEN OF ABOUT 40% OF OUR OF
OUR YOUNG FOLKS TODAY WAIT UNTIL
AFTER AGE EIGHTEEN BUT THE
RESEARCHERS SHOWN IT'S NOT
BECAUSE OF THE GDL IS BECAUSE OF
ECONOMICS.
NO I I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT WHAT
I'M SAYING THAT YOU'RE COMPARING
THE ACCIDENT RATES.
OF A GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SELF SELECTED TO OPT INTO THIS
PROGRAM AS A AS OPPOSED TO
PEOPLE WHO WAIT AND THEN DON'T
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF THE PROGRAM --
NO THE SIXTEEN SEVENTY ROLES OF
THE GET THEIR LICENSE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH G. DEAL RIGHT SO WHAT
THAT GIVES US AND WHAT IT GIVES
US A NOTE ALL THE OTHER FIFTY
STATES AS WE CAN RESEARCH.
WHERE THE FATALITIES HAPPEN SO
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN OR TWENTY YEAR
OLDS THAT CAN JUST WALK IN AND
GET THEIR LICENSE UNLIKE OLDER
TWENTY YEAR OLDS AND I CAN GO
INTO THAT TOO IF YOU WANT?
BUT THOSE FOLKS EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND TWENTY YEAR OLDS --
THAT DO NOT HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
GDL THEIR FATALITY CRASH RATE IS
4260% HIGHER.
IT'S 55% HIGHER THAN THOSE
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS
THAT GO THROUGH GDL AND THOSE
ARE FATAL ACCIDENTS RIGHT NOW I
UNDERSTAND I GUESS I'M JUST
MAKING THE POINT THAT I THINK
YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF STRONG
CORRELATION.
BUT THAT'S NOT EXACTLY THE SAME
AS TAKING TO POPULATIONS THAT
ARE THE SAME AND THEN HAVING ONE
GO THROUGH THE PROGRAM AND ONE
NOT THESE ARE THESE ARE
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS ONE IS
OLDER -- THERE'S A VARIETY OF
REASONS SO I'M JUST I GUESS MY
POINT IS JUST I WAS NINE I THINK
THIS PROGRAM IS GREAT AND I'M
SURE THERE IS.
I DON'T THINK THAT THE CORAL IF
YOU KNOW YOUR YOU ARE TALKING TO
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS AND PEOPLE
WHO ARE SELF SELECTING WHETHER
IT'S TO GET THEIR LICENSE AT A
CERTAIN AGE OR NOT -- SO I DON'T
THINK THAT.
THE BECAUSE I DON'T THE
CORRELATION IS EXACTLY IS SORT
OF SCIENTIFICALLY PROVEN AS
YOU'RE MAKING IT OUT TO BE I'M
NOT SAYING THAT THERE'S NOT SOME
CORRELATION THERE BUT IT'S NOT
THE SAME AS IF YOU TOOK ONE
GROUP OF SIXTEEN YEAR OLDS.
AND ONE GROUP THAT YOU KNOW AND
AND ONE PORT ONE GROUP OF
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS.
THAT'S EXACTLY THE SAME AND
RANDOMIZE THEM TO TWO DIFFERENT --
TWO DIFFERENT PROGRAMS IT'S A
LITTLE IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT AND WHAT YEAR OLD
MIGHT YOU KNOW DR.
DIFFERENTLY THEY HAVE TWO MORE
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE THEY MAY
DRIVE DIFFERENTLY THAN EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD GETTING A LICENSE FOR
THE FIRST TIME I'M JUST SAYING
THAT IF YOU PUT EIGHTEEN
ENROLLED IN THE SAME PROGRAM YOU
MIGHT NOT GET THE EXACT SAME
RESULT AS PUTTING SOMEBODY
FIFTEEN INTO IT.
THAT'S ALL I'M NOT I'M NOT
ARGUING I'M JUST SAYING YOU'RE
NOT EXACTLY THE SAME POPULATIONS
THAT WE WE HAVE CRASH DATA FROM
INDIANA IN NEW JERSEY THAT HAVE
GONE TO TWENTY ONE SO WE KNOW
WHAT THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY OR LOOK LIKE WHEN THEY
WHEN THEY GO THROUGH ITS.
BUT YOUR YOUR POINTS WILL TAKE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA YEAH --
AS A LONG TIME -- HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER.
THAT YEAR AFTER YEAR -- SAW.
THE TRAGEDIES OF SOMETIMES --
YOUNG PEOPLE AGO GOT INVOLVED IN
AN AND AND ALSO -- NUMEROUS
DEATHS IN MY TWENTY YEARS OF
TEACHING I SUPPORTED THIS BILL
THE LAST TIME AND WHEN I THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD AGAIN THIS YEAR AND I
WILL SUPPORT IT AGAIN.
ANY OTHER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I THINK.
WE'VE GOT A PROBLEM KIDS ARE
WAITING LONGER TO GET THEIR
DRIVER'S LICENSE THEY'RE THEY'RE
ABLE TO ESSENTIALLY.
EVADE THE INTENT IN A WAY OF
WHAT THE GRADUATED LICENSE
PROGRAM IN THE ADDITIONAL
TRAINING IT PROVIDES TWO YOUNG
DRIVERS.
WAS SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE.
I THINK THAT'S A FAIR POINT
ABOUT THE DATA BUT I DO THINK
THERE'S SOME DATA SUGGESTING AT
LEAST THAT -- THEPUBLIC SAFETY
AND OUR ROAD SAFETY WOULD
BENEFIT FROM HAVING EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY YEAR OLDS GO
THROUGH A RATHER TRUNCATED
PROGRAM BUT STILL PROGRAM WHERE
THEY GET SOME TRAINING.
AND IN MY PROFESSIONAL LIFE AS
AN ATTORNEY I'VE SEEN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DO A LOT OF DUMB
THINGS IN CARS AND I'VE SEEN A
LOT OF TRAGEDY COME FROM SO.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A WERE
THE BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT.
TODAY AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR DAILY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANNA FOLLOW UP ON THE COMMENTS
ALL OF WHICH I AGREE WITH IN.
THE SALUTE THE AUTHOR FOR DOING
A NICE JOB TO SUMMARIZE -- WHAT
YOU'D LIKE TO DO HERE AND ALSO
WERE IT CERTAINLY DOES?
IT'S A GREAT FOLLOW UP ON THE
WORK THAT ARE CHAIR HAS DONE ON
THIS SUBJECT OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS SO THANK YOU AND NAMA.
IN TWO ZERO SIX SUPPORTER OF THE
BILL.
THE QUESTION IS OF THE AUTHOR OF
THE COMMITTEE.
SO THREE THIS WAS LIKE CLOSE --
YOU KNOW I I CERTAINLY --
APPRECIATE AGAIN MISTER ALL OF
THE WORK IN THE COMMENTS I THINK.
THE COMMENT THAT MISS WE DO MADE
IS A GOOD ONE YOU KNOW WE DON'T
KNOW.
YOU KNOW IF IF IT DOES BECOME
LAW.
YOU KNOW WEEK YOU KNOW WE DON'T
ANTICIPATE THAT THE IMPACT IS
GOING TO BE A GOOD.
ONE BUT CERTAINLY THOSE FACTORS
AS FAR AS YOU KNOW THE INFLUENCE
THAT IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY
ROLES GONNA HAVE IN THIS PROGRAM
YOU KNOW THE KIND OF SUPPORT
THEY GONNA GET FROM THE PARENTS
WILL KIND OF YOU KNOW
INVOLVEMENT IS THE IS.
MUCH DIFFERENT THAN IF YOU HAVE
SOMEONE WHO'S -- FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
YOU KNOW OR MUCH YOUNGER -- BUT
WE CAN ONLY I ANTICIPATE GOOD
OUTCOMES FROM THIS BECAUSE
CERTAINLY -- IT'S MUCH BETTER
THAN WHAT WE HAVE -- AND NO YOU
KNOW WE CAN I JUST PAY TO HAVE --
DEPOSIT OUT AND BUT WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BOTH
ON AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
TIMES TO CHECK.
AND THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
SUMMARY OF THIS -- AS MANY ON
THE COMMITTEE ALREADY KNOW
EXTENDING CALIFORNIA'S
PROVISIONAL DRIVER'S LICENSE.
PROGRAM UP TO TWENTY ONE YEARS
OLD HAS BEEN A PRIORITY OF MINE.
ACCORDING TO THE CDC AND THAT'S
A DRIVERS TO GO THROUGH A
PROVISIONAL LICENSING PERIOD
EXPERIENCE. 4260% FEWER VEHICLE
CRASHES THAN THOSE WHO WAIT
UNTIL THEY'RE EIGHTEEN TO GET
THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSE.
CAR CULTURE IS NT WHAT IT USED
TO BE.
OVER 30% OF OUR DRIVERS ARE
WAITING UNTIL THEY ARE EIGHTEEN
OR OLDER TO GET A LICENSE.
EXTENDING OUR PTO REQUIRES TOLD
DRIVERS WILL ONLY MAKE SURE OUR
ROADS ARE SAFER FOR EVERYBODY.
AS A PARENT WHO LOST A CHILD.
IN A CAR ACCIDENT.
I IMPLORE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
FIRST BUT I GUESS THE SECOND.
AMERICA SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
FONG [inaudible]
FONG NOW [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY.
I YEAR CURRY NOT VOTING FOR
BERMAN.
AND I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING CHAIR.
YOU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY AYE DALY AYE
DEEP HI DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON I GRAYSON.
MEDINA -- MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL NOT VOTING.
BUT AS NINE BELIEVE THROUGH OPEN --
FOR APPS AND OF MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF ONE ALL.
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE -- TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FIGURE CURRY --
WE'RE GOING TO GO -- TO AB.
NINE NINE EIGHT PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AB NINE NINE EIGHT OUT STATE
HIGHWAY ONE TWENTY EIGHT TO THE
LIST OF HIGHWAYS ELIGIBLE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA SCENIC HIGHWAY
PROGRAM.
HIGHWAY ONE TWENTY EIGHT RUNS
FROM THE COAST OF MENDOCINO TO
MY HOME TOWN WINTERS CALIFORNIA
IN YOLO COUNTY.
IS NESTLED AGAINST COASTAL
MOUNTAINS AND SCENIC LANDSCAPES
ALONG THE WAY THERE ARE WINERIES
VINEYARDS MICHELIN STAR
RESTAURANTS AND WORLD CLASS
RESORTS.
IN ORDER FORMALLY ESTABLISH A
HIGHWAYS A SCENIC A SCENIC THERE
IS A MULTI STEP LOCAL
APPLICATION PROCESS DONE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH LOCAL AGENCIES
THE PUBLIC IN CALTRANS.
LEGISLATION ADDING THE HIGHWAY
TO THE STREETS AND HIGHWAYS CODE
IS REQUIRED AS A FIRST STEP.
AB NINE NINE IT DOES JUST THAT.
AB EIGHT NINE NINE EIGHT WILL
ALLOW LOCALS AND TO INITIATE THE
SCENIC HIGHWAY PROCESS I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND I'VE GOT WITH
ME TODAY -- CHRIS TOOK A RICH ON
BEHALF OF TURKISH FAMILY WINDS.
DECISION THAT OBVIOUSLY AGAIN
AND THE REST OF THE RECORD
PLEASE [inaudible]
FIND.
AND A FARMER AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER IN WINTERS CALIFORNIA.
A BRIEF PICTURE OF OF ONE TWENTY
EIGHT THE DIVERSITY AND BEAUTY
AND IT HAS.
A CONNECTS THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY
STARTING IN WINNERS -- TO THE
MENDOCINO COAST PASSING THROUGH
NAPA AND SONOMA COUNTIES.
HAS DIVERSE LANDSCAPE RANGING
FROM FARMLANDS LIKE WE HAVE AN
WINTERS LIKE BERRYESSA THE NEW
NATIONAL MONUMENT.
SNOW MOUNTAIN ALONG WITH THE
WINE COUNTRY THE RUSSIAN RIVER --
REDWOODS AND FINALLY THE THE
MENDOCINO COAST -- IN ADDITION
TO THE NATURAL BEAUTY THAT WE
HAVE ALONG THIS ROUTE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO DEFY THE THE
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THEY ADD TO
THE EXPERIENCE.
OF WINTERS REPRESENTS THE SECOND
LARGEST COMMUNITY ON THIS ROUTE --
SO THE COMMUNITIES WINTERS
SALENA CALISTOGA GEYSER BILL
CLOVERDALE BOONVILLE FILO AND
NAVARRO ARE ALL THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THAT MAKE THE BACKBONE OF
THIS THIS ROUTE -- SO FINALLY
IT'S RELAXING EXPERIENCE THAT
HAS CAN ACTIVITY THROUGH --
HIGHWAY ONE ON THE WEST HI A ONE
A ONE AND HIGHWAY. TWENTY NINE
IN THE INTERIOR AND THEN ACCESS
ON THIS HE SIGHED THROUGH
WINNERS AND HIGHWAY -- FOUR OH
FIVE SO I KNOW THAT'S IT THE
CRITICAL PIECE AS FAR AS IN
ADDITION TO BEAUTY IS IS
CONNECTIVITY.
FINALLY THIS IS A GEM OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND IT'S AN
EXPERIENCE OF NOT NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN A HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO MILES -- SIMPLY BOIL
DOWN SO.
THANK YOU FOR THE CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ALL THIS
WAY TESTIFYING.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY COVERS THE
PUBLIC.
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
SHARE CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHORS
BILL.
SEEING NONE SPECIAL COMMITTEE
THREE OF US.
YEAH I MOVED THE BILL BUT YOU
KNOW I'M REALLY KIND OF ON THE
FENCE IS THIS GOES TO THE FLOOR
SO I'M GOING TO SUGGEST THAT WE
ORGANIZE A LITTLE TOY MORE. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ALL REALLY
ON BOARD WITH THIS MAYBE OVER
THE THE SPRING BREAK SELF JUST
THROWING IT OUT THERE YOU MIGHT
DO BETTER AS THIS MOVES FORWARD
IF WE ORGANIZE.
MAYBE A COMMITTEE TOUR JUST A
SUGGESTION SO YOU'RE SAYING
CONDITIONAL.
ADDITIONAL BECAUSE I'VE NEVER
ACTUALLY GONE DOWN MOST OF THIS
HIGHWAY AND VERY INTERESTED ALSO
IN YOUR FARM SO.
SHOULD WE COULD ARRANGE A VISIT.
WELL WE HAVE LOTS OF A SECOND
YEAH.
MR BIGELOW.
AT THANK YOU JUST KIND OF
ACTUALLY GOING ON WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING THERE BUT A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
SERIOUSNESS FOR A MOMENT -- HAVE
YOU HAD THE CONVERSATION WITH
THE LOCALS.
YES AND I KNOW YOU'VE GOT A
REPRESENTATIVE HERE.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN AN ELABORATE ARE
THEY AWARE OF ALL THE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS WHAT THIS IS GOING TO
MEAN AND LIFESTYLE CHANGES FOR
THEM.
SO WE DO KNOW THIS IS THE VERY
FIRST STEP YES IS A PUBLIC OUT
REACH STILL WE NEED TO GET DONE
ABSOLUTELY.
THIS GROUP THAT HAS PUT THIS
TOGETHER IT HAS BEEN DOING THIS
FOR ABOUT A COUPLE YEARS THEY'VE
BEEN. THREE YEARS MEETING WITH
SUPERVISORS -- BUSINESSES ALONG
THAT ROUTE CURRENTLY AND WHEN
THEY WERE QUITE SURE WHAT STEPS
TO TAKE AND NOT REALIZING THIS
IS THE VERY FIRST STEP WE NEED
TO TAKE.
BUT THEY'VE ALREADY DONE PUBLIC
OUTREACH WE HAVE HAD CINEMA
COUNTY -- COME ON BOARD NAPA
COUNTY SO WE HAVE THE COUNTY
SOMEWHERE BUT WE HAVE TO WORK
WITH THE PROPERTY OWNERS WE DO
KNOW THE SIGNAGE ISSUES.
SO WE DO KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF OBSTACLES TILT THE STILL THE
GUY COME OUR WAY WE THINK WE CAN
DO IT WE'VE DONE -- THEY HAVE
DONE INCREDIBLE PUBLIC OUTRAGE
MOVING FORWARD AND I THINK THAT --
IT'S GOING TO BENEFIT A LOT OF
OUR AREA THIS GOING THROUGH A
LOT OF ECONOMIC TURMOIL SINCE
THE FIRES.
SO JUST JUST KIND OF BECAUSE I'M
PROBABLY THE ONLY ONE UP HERE
IT'S ACTUALLY.
BEEN A PART OF ONE OF THOSE
PROCESS SEES -- HAVING BEEN A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR WHERE IT
STARTED HERE AND A GROUP MADE
THAT HAPPEN AND THEN IT WAS.
BROUGHT TO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WERE ULTIMATELY IT --
DID GET ADOPTED ALTHOUGH
MODIFIED FOR THE AREA THAT WAS
TO BE TRAVEL.
WHAT US IN SUIT THERE WAS A REAL
CHALLENGE FOR THE PEOPLE BECAUSE
THOSE PEOPLE WHO HAD NICE WHITE
PICKET FENCES COULD NO LONGER
HAVEA?
THOSE AT HIM MAILBOXES CAN NO
LONGER HAVE A THOSE IT HAD JUST
A FIELD FENCE TO KEEP THEIR
CONSTANT COULD NO LONGER HAVE IT.
THOSE THAT HAD HOUSES -- AND
TREES THAT THEY WERE FARMING
COULD NO LONGER HAVE IT.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF LAND USE
ISSUES.
IN THE DETAIL OF ALL OF THIS
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
DEALT WITH AND IT BECOMES A
NIGHTMARE.
HEAVEN HELP YOU AS THIS MOVES
FORWARD I DON'T THINK THAT IT'S
ONE I DON'T THINK IT'S AS EASY
AS JUST A SIMPLE VOTE HERE TODAY
SO.
I WOULD CAUTION YOU AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD.
WITH THIS PROCESS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR REMARKS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE
DO NOT REALIZE THAT THERE IS
GOING TO BE -- A LOT OF TO
CONVERSATIONS THAT CAN HAPPEN
WILL HAPPEN -- CURRENTLY THEY
HAVE A WEBSITE I BELIEVE IT WAS.
IT'S CALLED VISIT ONE TWENTY
EIGHT SO THEY CAN SO THEY'VE
ALREADY STARTED DOING SOME
PUBLIC OUT REACH -- I GOTTA TELL
YOU THIS IS A VERY THOUGHTFUL
MINDFUL GROUP THAT'S WORKING ON
THIS AND AND FOR ME IT'S A
PLEASURE THAT THEY HAVE TAKEN
THE INITIATIVE. TO HELP ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT HELP TO SMALL BIT
THE BUSINESSES ALONG THE WAY AND
MAKE THIS TRULY A SUCCESSFUL A
SCENIC HIGHWAY SO I I WILL I
TAKE THAT INTO CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE SIMILAR WHICH LIKE
CLOTHES -- I SIMPLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE IN YES ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
TO COME I WILL BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO DO A TOUR FROM WINTERS.
ALL THE WAY AS FAR AS YOU CAN
GET ON THE WINE TRAIL AND WE'LL
SEE WHERE WE END UP BUT YEAH I'D
BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO DO THAT.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
AND AND ADVOCATING FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND SUSTAINABILITY
IN YOUR IN YOUR DISTRICT.
OF AND JUST TO COMMENT WITH
MISTER BIGELOW.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
HIGH SPEED RAIL [inaudible]
SO.
SALUTE YOUR CONCERNS ARE YEAH
[inaudible]
SO -- AND AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR A RINGS FAN AND COMING
ALL THIS WAY FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
ADVOCATING FOR YOUR COMMUNITY.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR
BUILDING THANK YOU REVEREND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER YES FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG AYE.
HI THANK YEAR CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING CHIU. TWO I
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING DAILY --
BY CUNNINGHAM AYE [inaudible]
DALY.
DALY AYE DEEP.
DEEP NOT VOTING FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON ON HERE GRAYSON
[inaudible]
MEDINA.
MEDINA I NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I SO THAT'S WILL HIT
HAS -- ELEVEN WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE CONTRAPTION MEMBERS THANK
YOU [inaudible]
MR VOTE.
WE WILL NOW MOVE -- TO FILE ITEM.
FOR A AB.
SEVEN ZERO EIGHT I'M NOT SURE
WHEN YOU CAN BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
AB SEVEN AWAIT CLOSES A LOOPHOLE.
THAT ALLOWS ONLINE TRAFFIC
VIOLATORS SCHOOLS TO CREATE
HUNDREDS OF SIMILARLY NAMED
SCHOOLS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DOMINATING.
THE BILL CAN BE REFERRAL SECOND.
WITH THAT.
COOL AFTER CHRIS TO OUR
WITNESSES BECAUSE THEY TRAVEL
DISTANCES TO COME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MADAM CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS -- SCOTT QUESTION BEHALF
OF THE DISTANCE LEARNING COMPANY --
AS THE AUTHOR HAS POINTED OUT.
THE GAME HAS BECOME IN THE
TRAFFIC VIOLATORS SCHOOL
REGISTERING AS MANY NAMES AS
POSSIBLE ON THE LIST.
BECAUSE YOU'RE OPPORTUNITY OF
THROUGH RANDOM SELECTION OF
GETTING SELECTED BY CONSUMERS IS
IS A HIGHER WITH EACH ONE SO.
TODAY CALIFORNIA HAS SLIGHTLY
OVER TWENTY NINE HUNDRED TRAFFIC
VIOLATORS SCHOOLS. FIVE
COMPANIES OWN OVER TWO THOUSAND
OF THOSE. ONE COMPANY ALONE HAS.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THEY REGISTERED
A HUNDRED NEW SCHOOL NAMESTHIS
MONTH FIVE HUNDRED IN JANUARY.
THIS NOT ONLY HURTS LEGITIMATE
BUSINESSES LIKE MY CLIENT.
IT DECEIVED CONSUMERS.
ANNA BURDENS THE DMV YOU HAS TO
PROCESS IN YOUR WOOL.
OF APPLICATION RENEWALS FOR EACH
ONE OF THESE THREE ALMOST THREE
THOUSAND SCHOOLS.
AND IS RENDERED THE AUDIT
PROCESS THE RANDOM AUDIT PROCESS
VIRTUALLY MEANINGLESS BECAUSE
THE SCHOOLS ARE OWNED.
OF VIRTUALLY BY THE SAME IT'S A
TEASE.
BEFORE HEADED OVER TO OUR OTHER
WITNESSES I'LL JUST POINT OUT TO
YOU -- THIS IS WHAT THE THE
COURTS HAND OUT TO FOLKS.
PAGE AFTER PAGE AFTER PAGE.
THE WRITING IS SO SMALL NOW BUT
EVEN WITH MY GLASSES I CAN'T I
CAN'T READ IT.
ORANGE COUNTY ALONE IS IS
PUBLISHING TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
COPIES OF THIS PER MONTH.
AT A COST OF LIKE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH.
IT IT'S GOTTEN OUT OF CONTROL
IT'S HURTING CONSUMERS AND WE
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE HAVE A
COUPLE VERY QUICK WITNESSES FOR
YOU THANK YOU.
AT THE VERY MUCH PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READY.
MADAM CHAIRMAN -- IN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR LET
ME SPEAK TODAY -- I URGE YOUR
EYES FOR THIS -- ON AB SEVEN
AWAIT.
I I I NOT SURE IF ANYBODY GOT
THIS IF YOU GUYS ALL GOT THIS.
I JUST PUT TOGETHER A QUICK
LITTLE SUMMARY WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE -- AB TWO FOUR NINE NINE
HAD A COUPLE NEW POLLS LEFT IN
IT THAT WE WERE GOING TO CLOSE
UP EVENTUALLY IN THIS IS THE
TIME TO DO IT.
MAINLY THE LIST MANIPULATION IS
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM.
IF YOU LOOK ON THIS SHEET THAT
ID THAT I GIVE YOU PROBABLY --
STARTING ON PAGE THREE TALK
ABOUT EXAMPLES OF THE THINK
SCHOOLS.
YOU'LL SEE ON THERE.
THERE'S FIVE THIS SCHOOL HAS
FOURTEEN HUNDRED NAMES ON THE
LIST AND THEY HAVE FOURTEEN
HUNDRED IDENTICAL WEBSITES IF
YOU LOOK AT PAGE ONE THROUGH
FIVE THE ONLY THING THAT HAS
CHANGED.
IS NUMBER ONE AFTER THE NAME
NUMBER TWO AFTER THE NAMES
NUMBER THREE AFTER THE NAME ALL
THE WAY THROUGH.
THANK YOU WOULD HAVE TO FOURTEEN
HUNDRED OF THOSE.
FINALLY ITEM I WOULD HAPPEN TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE THE CUSTOMER
REVIEWS ON EACH OF THE WEBSITES
AND THEY'RE THE EXACT SAME.
SO THESE ARE NOT INDEPENDENTLY
RUNNING SCHOOLS THESE ARE FRONTS.
THESE ARE SHAMS AND THERE ARE
MISLEADING THE CONSUMER TO
BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE CHOICE.
ANOTHER VERY IMPORTANT FACTOR
BEFORE I GO.
IS IT'S AGAIN.
WHAT MISTER WHICH SAYS IT'S
COSTLY TO THE TAXPAYERS THE OF
FREE ADVERTISING?
AND FREE MARKETING TO THE CAN UP
FOR THE BUSINESSES AND THEY
SHOULDN'T GET THIS FREE
MARKETING -- WHEN IT'S REALLY
JUST A FRONT?
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WASN'T NEXT WITNESS HI MS LARSON
WHICH YOU ALONG WITH BUT ALL
KINDS -- WE CAN IN THE TRAFFIC
SAFETY INDUSTRY NOW 420- YEARS.
AND JUST ROAD BRIEFLY -- WE WANT
TO TALK WITH THE IMPACT AND
CONSUMER HE CREATES CONFUSION --
FOR FOR THE CONSUMER AS A SIGN
OF FOR ONE COURSE THAT HAS THE
EXACT SAME NAME AS ANOTHER
COURSE JUST WITH A DIFFERENT
NUMBER AT THE END -- SO DURING
THE COURSE OF THE SHOULD NEED
ASSISTANCE.
GETTING HOLD OF SOMEONE BASED ON
AT THE EXACT SAME NAME GOING TO
THAT LIST AGAIN IS VERY
PROBLEMATIC A LOT OF TIMES ARE
UNABLE TO GET THAT ASSISTANCE OR
ONCE YOU'VE COMPLETED THE COURSE
A YEAR LATER.
IF THEY NEED A ANOTHER
RECERTIFICATION OR THE TO
DUPLICATE THE TICKET WE FINDING
THAT SCHOOL AGAIN ON THAT LIST
IS ALMOST NEXT TO IMPOSSIBLE.
LAST NIGHT ALSO POINT OUT THAT.
GIVEN THESE PROBLEMS THAT THE
CONSUMER MIGHT FACE WITH ONE OF
THESE SCHOOLS IF -- SEVERAL
YEARS LATER THEY DECIDE THAT
THEY HAVE TO TAKE ANOTHER
RECIPROCATION COURSE IN A
TRAFFIC SCHOOL COURSE TRYING TO
AVOID THAT SAME BAD ACTORS
ALMOST NEXT IMPOSSIBLE SINCE
THEY HAVE SUCH MANIPULATION ON
THE LIST.
YOU HAD A BAD EXPENSES ONE UNIT
TO VOTE IN THE FUTURE YOU'VE
WRITTEN UP ALL RIGHT AT THE
EXACT SAME SCHOOL AGAIN SEVERAL
YEARS LATER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
PLEASE REPEAT MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU GERRY ALEXANDER.
DIRECTIVE EDUCATION CONCEPTS
WE'VE BEEN DOING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND A JUST SENTENCE ME TO
SEE HOW AN INDUSTRY THAT CAN
SAVE LIVES JUST GOT KID THAT BY
A FEW MONEY GRABBING INDIVIDUALS --
BUT ONE OF THE AND I CALLED.
THE TESTIMONY.
THAT WE JUST HEARD.
IS REALLY TRUE AND AND AND
PRESIDENT BUT I ALSO WANT TO
TESTIFY ANOTHER SUBJECT AND
THAT'S CONSUMER SECURITY -- DMV
RULES REGULATING TRAFFIC WITH A
SCHOOL INDUSTRY BEEN WRITTEN
MANY YEARS AGO BEFORE THE ADVENT
OF THE ONLINE EDUCATION.
CURRENTLY SCHOOLS COLLECT ONE OF
THE MOST SENSITIVE DATA.
OUT THERE WE COLLECT NAME HOME
ADDRESS DRIVER'S LICENSE.
OF EACH OF EACH STUDENT.
THERE IS CURRENTLY ABSOLUTELY NO
PROVISIONS WITH.
WITH WITH WITHIN THE REGULATIONS
THAT MANDATE THAT THAT SECURITY
IS PROTECTED -- THE MATTER OF
FACT YOU'LL FIND THE PICTURE IN
YOUR PACKETS.
THIS IS THE FRONT DOOR TO THE
GLOBAL HEADQUARTERS OF THE
COMPANY THAT THE PRESENTS
FOURTEEN HUNDRED SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S THAT'S THE OFFICE OF
FRIDAY MORNING [inaudible]
SO.
WE DEFINITELY SEE THIS AS A PART
YOU ENERGY HAS TO CLEAN UP THE
INDUSTRY AND A LEGITIMIZING.
I IMPROVE SECURITY FOR CONSUMERS --
AND BY AND BY THE WAY NOT NOT
NOT ONLY ITS EXPOSES THE DATA
THAT WE COLLECT WHICH ARE
MILLIONS OF STUDENT RECORDS --
ITS EXPORT THIS IDEA IN THE AYE
IF YOU'RE A MEMBER FOR YEARS AGO
WE HAD A CASE WITH WERE TARGET
DATE WAS -- HAD.
MILLIONS OF REC -- PRIVATE THAT
GREAT GUARDS WERE EXPOSED.
THAT HACKER FIND ITS WAY INTO
TARGET.
THROUGH A SMALL IF REGENERATION
REPAIR COMPANY BECAUSE THEY DID
NOT FOLLOW PROPER PROTOCOLS.
EACH TRAFFIC SCHOOL CURRENTLY
CONNECTS TO THE DMV TO REPORT
STUDENT COMPLETIONS SO WE REALLY
HAVE A DIRECT PIPELINE TO THE
ENTIRE D. V. IF ONE OF THE
SCHOOLS ATTACK.
THANK YOU.
I THINK VERY MUCH WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRODUCE THE SPEAK IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
MEN [inaudible]
BILL.
BUT A VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
OTHER INDIVIDUALS IN THE PUBLIC
THAT LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY.
ANYONE IN THE PUBLIC THAT LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME ON UP BUT HIM
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
PAUL CURRY ON BEHALF OF TRAFFIC
ONE ONE DOT COM.
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT WE
DID HAVE AN OPPOSITION LETTER
DELIVERED TO THE COMMITTEE OF
THE RIVER.
ANALYSIS DOES NOT REFLECT THAT
THE AMENDMENTS WE WERE NOT ABLE
TO OBTAIN THE AMENDMENTS UNTIL
THE TWENTY FIFTH WHEN THEY WERE
RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC WE HAD
ACTUALLY CONTACTED THE AUTHORS
OFFICE TRYING TO GET THE COPIES
OF THE AMENDMENTS.
WE WERE EVEN INFORMED WHO THE
SPONSORS OF THE LEGISLATION WAS
UNTIL LATER IN THE DAY.
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE HEARING SO
WE DROPPED A LETTER OFTEN
OPPOSITION ON THE TWENTY SIX
BEFORE NOON I PERSONALLY DROPPED
THAT LETTER BOTH THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF SO THAT WE
COULD BE ON TOP.
OF ON THE RECORDS SOMEONE TO
MAKE THAT CLEAR TO THE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE THIS IS BEEN A VERY
DIFFICULT A BILL. FOR US TRYING
TO WORK ON TRYING TO FIND WHO WE
NEEDED TO TALK TO WE WE NEVER
BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT WE'VE BEEN
WILLING TO TRY TO WORK WITH
PEOPLE -- THAT'S NOT BEEN
POSSIBLE SO I HAVE A PMR CLIENT
HERE WHO WILL EXPLAIN.
OUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE
ENTER NAME AND PRETTY WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ARMAND JUST MILLION I'M THE
OWNER OF TRAFFIC ONE ONE DOT COM
I'VE BEEN IN THE INDUSTRY TWENTY
PLUS YEARS OF ALONG WITH MR SOLD
THIS WEEK.
PIONEERED IN A SENSE THIS
INDUSTRY -- VERY LONG TIME AGO --
I'M SPEAKING TO IN OPPOSITION OF
AB SEVEN AWAITS.
THERE'S NO ARGUMENT THAT A
HANDFUL TRAFFIC SCHOOLS OWNERS
HAVE GROSSLY ABUSED AND
MANIPULATED TVS LIST I AM IN
COMPLETE AGREEMENT THAT THE
SCHOOLS ARE OF THE PLATING THIS
LIST IN THE SENATE SUCH A WAY OF
USING THE SAME DOMAIN NAMES AND
SO FORTH -- HOWEVER IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE COMMITTEE
UNDERSTANDS BOTH -- SUPPORTERS
HIDDEN AGENDA AND ALSO THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT THIS BILL WILL
HAVE.
IN ITS CURRENT FORM THIS IS
PURELY SELF INTEREST BILL THAT
HAS VAGUE LANGUAGE DOES UNFAIR
TO SMALLER TVS COMPANIES AND
VERY COSTLY TO THE DMV.
FIRST OF SUPPORTERS WANT YOU TO
BELIEVE THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM
OF PRINTING ALL LICENSE SCHOOLS
ON PBS LISTA SOMEWHAT HARMFUL TO
THE PUBLIC.
AND I SAY ALL SCHOOLS MEANING
THERE ARE MANY SCHOOLS THAT DO
HAVE MULTIPLE SCHOOLS LIKE I DO
THAT DO IT IN NAME.
OF NON ABUSIVE WAY AS THE MAIN
OUR GROUP HAS DONE.
THIS CAN'T BE FURTHER SORRY --
THEY WANT YOU TO BELIEVE THAT
IT'S GOING TO HURT THE PUBLIC
BUT THIS CAN'T BE TRUE FOR THE
CAN BE FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH.
IN FACT THE RISE OF NUMBER
LICENSE SCHOOLS HAS INCREASED
COMPETITION IN THE INDUSTRY AND
RESULTING IN LOWERING THE COST
OF TRAFFIC SCHOOL COURSES WHICH
IS AN OBVIOUS BENEFIT TO THE
PUBLIC.
DOES SUPPORTERS SCHOOLS FOR
EXAMPLE CHARGE.
ON TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS FOR EACH
COURSE WELL MY COMPANY FIVE
DOLLAR TRAV SCHOOL DOT COM
CHARGES FIVE DOLLARS FOR THE
EXACT SAME SERVICE IN HISTORY
CONDITIONS EVEN MORE OF A
SERVICE.
THEIR TRAFFIC VIOLATORS HAVE
ALREADY PAID SEVERAL HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS IN FINES AND PENALTIES
SAVE THEM MONEY ON THE COST OF
YOUR TRIBE TRAFFIC SCHOOL SHOULD
BE IMPORTANT TO THIS COMMITTEE.
IT IS BECAUSE OF THIS INTENSE
COMPETITION DOUBLE SOME
SUPPORTERS FEEL THAT THE MOST
PASSED HIS BILL IN ORDER TO
RETURN THE GOOD OLD DAYS WHEN
THEY DOMINATED THE INDUSTRY.
IT'S A POINT TO NOTE ALSO THE
SUPPORT OF THE BILL HAVE BEEN
THIS INDUSTRY AS LONG AS I HAVE.
AND AGAIN BEFORE THE INDUSTRY
MODEL CHANGE STAYED TRULY DID
DOMINATE THE INDUSTRY.
SECOND THE VAGUE LANGUAGE OF
THIS BILL WAS WILL NOT SOLVE ANY
PROBLEMS BUT WILL ONLY BRING ON
NEW PROBLEMS AND HARM SOME VERY
ETHICAL TVS IS.
SUCH AS MY OWN IT IS VAGUE
LANGUAGE IN THIS CURRENT TVS
REGULATIONS THAT MADE IT IS THE
CURRENT TVS REGULATIONS THAT
MADE IT EASY FOR ME IN OUR GROUP
THOUSANDS OF SCHOOLS.
USING A AN UNSCRUPULOUS BUSINESS
PRACTICES.
AS MR SOLD THIS MENTIONED MR MAN
ARGUES THE EXACT SAME WEBSITE
ADDRESS FOR HUNDREDS OF SCHOOLS
WHICH IS A CLEAR PROBLEM HOWEVER
ANOTHER NO NO WE'RE IN THEIR
CURRENT LEGISLATION IS THERE PRO --
PROPOSED BUDGET LOCAL
LEGISLATION IS A LANGUAGE TRYING
TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM.
IF THIS BILL PASSES CURRENT LAW
ABIDING SCHOOL BE NECK.
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED WHICH IS
PART OF THE SUPPORTERS INTENDS
TO WE CAN COMPETITION.
THE TRUE CAUSE OF THE INDUSTRY
THIS BILL AS AMENDED IS UNFAIR
VAGUE AND WILL BE VERY COSTLY
FOR THE DMV.
CURRENTLY EACH LICENSE SCHOOL
HAS A REQUIREMENT TO PAY YEARLY
DMV LICENSE FEE A HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS UP TWO
HUNDRED AND FIVE DOLLARS.
THE MUST CARRY FIFTEEN THOUSAND
ARE BOND AMONG OTHER FINANCIAL
REQUIREMENTS BY MEETING THESE
REQUIREMENTS CURRENT LEGISLATION
GRANTS EACH LICENSE SCHOOL THE
RIGHT TO AN INDIVIDUAL LISTING
ON THE LIST.
IF A GROUP OF SCHOOLS ONLY PURE
ONCE ON THE LIST.
AS THEY ARE PROPOSING IT IS ONLY
LOGICAL THAT THEY SHOULD ONLY
PAY ONE LICENSING FEE ONE BOND
AT CETERA.
HOWEVER THE PROPOSED BILL DOES
NOT AMEND ANY OF THE CURRENT
LEGISLATION LANGUAGE TO REFLECT
THIS.
THIS BILL ALSO FAILS TO EXPLAIN
HOW THE SCHOOLS WE GROUP ON A
LIST WILL ONLY ONE OF THE SCHOOL
MAYES WE LISTED IF THERE IS ONLY
ONE LISTING PER GROUP HOW WILL
THE PUBLIC BE ABLE TO VERIFY THE
LICENSE NUMBERS OF EACH SCHOOL
IN THE GROUP.
IS IT FAIR THAT THE COURTS AND
PUBLIC ARE LEFT STRUGGLING TO
MAKE SENSE OF IT ALL.
BUT THE MOST DANGEROUS ASPECT OF
ALL IS THE WAY THE BILL DEFINES
AFFILIATED TRAFFIC SO THEY'LL
MAY LATER SCHOOLS OR THE WAY
THEY TRY TO GROUP THE SCHOOLS
LEAVING THE WIDE OPEN FOR
MISINTERPRETATION AND ABUSE.
LET ME EXPLAIN THE BILL SITES
FOUR CRITERIA IN A SCHOOL WE
NEED TO MEET ONE OF THE CRITERIA
TO BE CONSIDERED PART AN
AFFILIATED GROUP WITH ANOTHER
SCHOOL.
EVEN IF THEY ARE NOT AFFILIATED
AT ALL UNDER THIS BILL TWO
SEPARATE SCHOOLS COULD HAVE
THEIR LICENSES REVOKED FOR ONE
YEAR.
ON A FIRST OFFENSE AND FIVE
YEARS FOR SECOND OFFENSE IF THEY
FEEL TO REPORTER AFFILIATION.
BASED ON THIS DEFINITION TO
SCHOOLS CANNOT BE. ONE BASED ON
THE CRITERIA FOR AFFILIATION IS
TO SCHOOLS CANNOT BE IN THE SAME
BUILDING.
IF FOR EXAMPLE OF TRAFFIC SCHOOL
ABC IS ALREADY IN GREAT BUILDING
WITH LOW RENT I CAN'T HAVE MY
OFFICE IN THE SAME BUILDING OR I
WILL CAN BE CONSIDERED AS A
GROUP OF LICENSE I'M SO I WILL
BEGROUP ALONG WITH THAT EVEN
THOUGH.
I MAY NOT EVEN KNOW THE COMPANY.
AND BOTH OF OUR LICENSES WILL BE
REVOKED. TWO TVS IS COULD NOT
SHARE THE SAME COMPUTER NETWORK
OR SERVER WHICH MEANS THAT IF TO
SCHOOLS ARE USING THE SAME
HOSTING SERVICES SUCH AS GO
GOOGLE GO THAT OUR AMAZON WEB
SERVICES.
YOUR CONSIDER GROUP.
THE SHARING OF TELEPHONE
SERVICES MANY LET A LEGITIMATE
SMALLER SCHOOLS GOING TO UTILIZE
THE SAME ANSWERING SERVICE WHICH
SPECIALIZES IN THIS INDUSTRY
THIS WOULD AND THAT'S REALLY FOR
SMALLER TVS IS TO OCCUR HARD
COSTS.
BECAUSE IT SAYS THEY CAN NO
LONGER USE THIS TYPE OF SERVICE.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE VERY REAL
POSSIBILITY THAT ONCE SIR I
THINK -- WE WOULD TRY TO KEEP
TIME LIMIT I UNDERSTAND BOTH
SIDES -- ONE MORE MINUTE I
REALLY AM FOUR POINT I'M SORRY I
APPRECIATE I APOLOGIZE.
UP AND THERE'S ALSO A HUGE
POSSIBILITY OF SABOTAGE THE WAY
THE LANGUAGE IS WRITTEN ANOTHER
SCHOOL CAN SIMPLY LEASED SPACE
IN THE SAME BUILDING HIGHER THE
SAME TELEPHONE CALL CENTER OR
EVEN TO USE THE SAME WEBSITE
HOSTING COMPANY.
AND THAT'LL AUTOMATICALLY.
GROUP THEM AND IT LONG AND THEY
WOULD HAVE NOT MENTIONED UP TO
THE DMV AND THEY'LL LOSE THEIR
LICENSE FOR A YEAR FOR LEASE FOR
THE FIRST OFFENSE -- THE LEGAL
ADMINISTRATIVE -- BOTH PARTS OF
THIS IS A NIGHTMARE FOR THE DMV.
I DO HAVE A COUPLE THINGS TO SAY
BUT I THINK I PRETTY MUCH
COVERED IT I DO APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S TIME.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BEFORE WE GET TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS ANY ADDITIONAL
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
I SAW SOMEONE GET UPSET IT AS
SEEN ON ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
IT'S GOING IN.
YEAH THIS IS MORE OF A QUESTION.
FOR THE OPPOSITION.
YEAH I HAVE I'M LOOKING AT THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND IT SAYS
TEXAS HAS FIFTY SEVEN OF THESE
SCHOOLS FLORIDA THIRTY THREE
FIFTEEN IN NEW YORK.
SURE THE LARGEST POPULATION
STATES RELATIVES CALIFORNIA.
UP WE'VE TWENTY NINE HUNDRED I I
I GUESS I JUST WANT.
I GET THAT YOU DON'T THINK THE
BILL'S PERFECT IN THEIR ASPECTS
OF THE PARTICULARS YOU DON'T
LIKE BUT ON A GENERAL LEVEL LIKE
WHO BENEFITS FROM HAVING.
LIKE WOOD MISTER WHAT SHOWED US
THESE PAGES THE COURTS HAND OUT
WITH THOUSANDS OF THESE THINGS
ON THIS ESSENTIALLY JUST.
A RANDOM.
DARK THROWS TO WHO GETS THE
BUSINESS AT A HOUSE THAT
BENEFITING THE CONSUMERS OR THE
OR THE SYSTEM OR HELPING PEOPLE
CLEAR UP TICKETS I DON'T I JUST
DON'T GET IT [inaudible]
WELL.
THANK YOU.
WELL AS FAR AS FEW OF THE OTHER
STATES TEXAS FOR EXAMPLE HAS A
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
APPLICATION FEE.
SO IT MAKES IT VERY HARD TO GET
ON THERE MORE THAN ONCE.
THAT'S ONE OF THE MAIN.
ENTRY THAT TEXAS DOES HAVE A NEW
YORK HAS FOURTEEN OR FIFTEEN
SCHOOLS NEW YORK HAS BEEN IN A
PILOT PROGRAM FOR ALMOST TEN
YEARS NOW -- THE STATE HOUSE
COMPLETELY SHUT IT DOWN IF I
WANTED TO START A COUPLE --
TRAFFIC'S WOUND AT NEW YORK I
CANNOT BECAUSE BUT LEGISLATION
WILL NOT ALLOW ME INTO THE PILOT
PROGRAM IS FINISHED.
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED SCHOOLS ON
THE LIST AND YOU KNOW TWO
THOUSAND AND BEING FOR ONE
SCHOOL IS RIDICULOUS ESPECIALLY
THE WAY THEY'RE DOING IT.
THERE IS AN OLD MAIN BENEFIT TO
IT BUT MY ARGUMENT ISN'T
NECESSARILY TO ALLOW TO HAVE TWO
THOUSAND SCHOOLS MY ARGUMENT IS
THE WAY THE LANGUAGE IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
IT IS JUST A RECIPE FOR DISASTER
L. AS I EXPLAINED.
IT WILL.
THE BILL IT FOR ONE SCHOOL TO
SABOTAGE ANOTHER AND ABILITY AYE
I COULD GO AND RENT AN OFFICE
BASEMENT BUILDING AND HAVE NO
IDEA MY COMPETITORS IN THERE
BECAUSE I DON'T.
I'M NOT CHECKING OBVIOUSLY AND I
COULD LOSE MY LICENSE BECAUSE I
DIDN'T KNOW I MEAN SOMETHING
JUST ISN'T RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
NOT TO MENTION THE COST THIS IS
GOING TO BRING ON THE DMV
THERE'S A SIMPLE SOLUTION FOR
THIS -- AND I'M OFFER TO SPEAK
WITH OUR SO WITH THESE
SUPPORTERS TO GIVE MY
SUGGESTIONS ON THIS ONE SIMPLE
SOLUTION ONE OF MANY IS TO
REQUIRE REGULATION THAT EACH
SCHOOL HAS A UNIQUE U. R. L..
SIMPLE MR MAIN ART WOULD HAVE TO
HAVE FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOMAINS
FIFTEEN HUNDRED WEBSITE AND SO
ON AND SO ON MR MEAN ARE ALSO
HAS ONE U. R. L. AND THE ALMOST
PROBABLY FILTER TO THE SCENE.
DATABASE THERE SHOULD BE A
REQUIREMENT THAT EACH SCHOOL
NEXT HAVE SEPARATE ACCESS
DATABASE Là DIFFERENT PASSWORDS
USER BASIC Y. OF IDEAS ARE NOT
IN LEGISLATION RIGHT NOW THAT
COULD BE.
I APPRECIATE THAT WITH THE
CHAIRS INDULGENCE COULD I GIVE
NATIONAL H..
TO UNITY TO RESPOND TO THAT
THANK YOU SIMILAR CUNNINGHAM
FIRST OF ALL -- THE OPPOSITION
HERE BY THE WAY IF YOU LOOK AT
YOUR LIST FIVE DOLLAR TRAFFIC
SCHOOL HE'S GOT APPROX THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SCHOOLS. HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE OF THEM START OFF
FIVE EIGHT IDENTICAL FIVE DOLLAR
TRAFFIC SCHOOL AND THEN YOU ADD
LIKE ONE TWO THREE OR TWO FOUR
SEVEN AT THE END OF IT HOW THAT
SERVES THE PUBLIC'S INTEREST.
I DON'T KNOW BUT THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL WAS TO CLEARLY GET OUT
WILL CONTINUE TO TIGHTEN
LANGUAGE I'M SURE DOING THAT THE
THE CHAIR IS A STICKLER -- TO
ENSURE THAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS IS PROGRAMS ARE CLEARLY
AFFILIATED THEY HAVE A CAUGHT
THEY SHARE REVENUE.
THEY SHARE A MAILING ADDRESS AS
WELL AS THE PHYSICAL ADDRESS SO
IT'S NOT JUST THAT YOU'RE IN THE
SAME BUILDING WE ACTUALLY HAVE
THE SAME MAILING ADDRESS BUT BUT
WE WE HAVE IS WE HAVE THE STRIP.
OF OF MALLS WHERE YOU HAVE
SOMEBODY THAT UNMARKED AD WITH A
ONE ADDRESS WITH. FIFTY SERVERS --
AND THE BILL WILL GET PO BOXES
FOR EACH AND EVERYONE OF THEM
TAKE TO GET AROUND THIS WE THINK
THE LANGUAGE IS PRETTY TIGHT.
WE DEFINE FOR DIFFERENT WAYS
WHAT AN AFFILIATED SCHOOLS ARE I
THINK ANY COMMON.
SENSE PURSUE LOOK AT AND SEE
WHAT WHAT WE'RE GETTING AT AND
AND HOW WOULD WORK WILL CONTINUE
TO TIGHTEN THAT.
BUT THAT'S THE ANSWER IS --
MISTER CUNNINGHAM THANK YOU.
AT THE VERY MUCH MUCH JIM ADDED
TO KNOW IF YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING.
DRESSED IN THE CLOTHES WILL DO.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS IN THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
AND THE SHOW JUST CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
AS A FORMER SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
WHEN I WAS APPROACHED WITH THIS
LIST.
I WAS ABSOLUTELY APPALLED.
THERE ARE CONSUMERS IN THE DMV
WAS BEING GAMES LIKE THIS.
AND FINDING A LOOPHOLE TO BE
ABLE TO TO CREATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY I THOUGHT WAS
APPALLING.
THAT'S WHY WE MOVED THE BILL
FORWARD WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
THERE'S POSSIBLY ISSUES GOT
POSITION MIGHT HAVE BROUGHT UP
SOME GOOD POINTS THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS GOING FORWARD.
THAT'S WHAT THIS PROCESS IS
ABOUT MOVING FORWARD AND
ADJUSTING AS WE SEE THINGS IT
WILL AUGMENT OR MAKE THE BILL
BETTER.
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IDEA
CURRY A SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
THE SCENE OF THE QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE CHIU.
CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DAILY OUR DAILY I
DEEP HI DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NOT VOTING MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
THIS AREA AND I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I THAT IS FORTY NICE.
AT GETS OUT LEAVE THE BELIEVE
THE ROLE OF AND WRAPS MEMBERS
THANK YOU AND IN THE SEARCH
REMEMBER
[inaudible]
YEAH.
SO WE WILL -- MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE COMMITTEE SECRETARY TO CALL
THE ROLL -- FOR STARTING FROM
THE CONSENT CALDERON WE GUESS
RIGHT -- UP WITH THE ABSENT
VOTERS.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BERMAN.
AND I CHU.
CHU AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL O'DONNELL
AYE.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB FIVE FIVE
THREE MELENDEZ THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY NO BERMAN.
BERMAN NO [inaudible]
THIS AREA.
NEWS AREA NO MEDINA.
DO YOU KNOW NO O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL NO.
THAT.
THE BILL OF FAILED WILL GRANT
RECONSIDERATION [inaudible]
BECAUSE RUSSIAN.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB SIX THIRTY
FOUR SALAS THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I MEDINA.
MEDINA I NAZARIAN [inaudible]
YES -- NOBLE O'KANE AREA NOT
VOTING O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I OKAY.
BERMAN.
BERMAN I NINE VOTES THE BILL IS
OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB SEVEN ZERO
EIGHT FRAZIER THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS -- GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NOT VOTING.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB NINE NINE
EIGHT AGUIAR-CURRY.
I HAVE A VERY AS AN AYE.
I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU FOR CHECKING MISTER
NAZARIAN.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB NINE NINE
EIGHT AGUIAR-CURRY THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS -- DEEP
[inaudible]
DEEP I GIPSON OUR GIPSON I
GRAYSON.
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL AYE -- SEARCHES PLEASE
CALL MISTER RAISINS OFFICES IF --
WE CAN GET MISSION [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY THAT MEASURE HAS FOURTEEN
VOTE.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB ELEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN MISTER MATHIS EMOTION IS
DO PASSED IN NATURAL RESOURCES.
BERMAN -- THE LOAN.
YES NO.
BERMAN NO CHILL.
CHIU NO.
GRAYSON [inaudible]
MEDINA.
MEDINA KNOWN AS AREA IN.
THIS AREA NO O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL NO [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE MEASURE FAILED WILL OF GRANT
RECONSIDERATION ALSO I THINK I
TOLD AUTHORS THAT.
OKAY THE FINAL OUTCOME.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN TWELVE SIXTY
SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER REINVEST
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
HEY -- GRAYSON [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
THE SYRIAN I THAT MEASURE HAS
TEN VOTE.
THE BILLS OUT
.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB SIX THIRTY
FOUR SALAS MR CHIU NOT VOTING TO
I THAT MEASURE HAS TEN VOTES.
SO LEAVE THIS -- THE ROLE OPEN
FOR A FEW MINUTES TO SEE IF MR
GRAYSON CAN MAKE IT BACK.
I THINK HE'S THE ONLY UPS A
MEMBER AT THIS POINT SO WE HAVE
A FEW MINUTES OF AND SEE IF WE
CAN CATCH UP WITH. FOR THAT WILL
HOLD OFF UNTIL YOU POSSIBLY
SHOPS
. ONE NEW INFORMATION WE'RE
GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLE.
DURING THE HEARING THIS
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION.
IS NOW COMPLETE THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED